I guess you can take some calls Listen
People
I might have any guests on the schedule
today I'm just going to go ahead and work on
some of my Organization for the the Boost
content while you guys while y'all are here
Sia 222
Burn Notice
I just made everything back to 12 cuz I'm
attending a 10 to sleep in on Saturday and
Sunday
cuz I said so I said till 7 a.m. today
can't help it so can I just do
when you look at it
I need to revisit what how we store data
I need to figure out how to store data
how to store data directly for for a
knowledge note
so we want to provide properties they start
your data properties for
something when it started hi Jerry I'm doing
pretty well
never know you should
there's an eighth there's not a 6 there's an
AMA are you talk about your Amy
I have a 6 a.m. a nice
aa've cement can have an email as well
the kind of stuck onI'm stuck on this idea
about how we're going to stay
skills to a specific we're going to have
Labs or not
and what difference between the lab what the
difference between a lab and that a project
is an exercise
and how do we how do we capture those
how's it going so sorry I have a thing
already
have these language challenges
yeah I built that our language agnostic and
what's going on with Cher let me have so
when we
we have a language challenge
what where can I project in the lab yeah
yeah
I mean there's there's multiple definitions
allow that's kind of problems to a lab is
also
here is a bunch of things you can do to test
it out like here do the lab like through the
chem lab for this particular project in the
lab right they call it a lab because
because it's in Loudon but it is confusing
right is it technically they're their
projects right
so
so yeah
so that makes me wonder about that actually
it makes me wonder if we should just call it
a project be done
exit polling mini projects
they are projects a project is like hey
here's a project right go to these things
what's the difference between a challenge
and a project would you say
when he hears hears our words that were
talking about here we have
I got two terms MD
so we have all these words that we use a lot
and I kind of want to get a handle on what
they are
so we have project we have live
we have yeah
less is more yes Avon
yeah I can't have a hard time moving on
because this is going to be codified in
thousands of things
I have an exercise we have a project we have
a task
and you're allowed right
cell
I think an exercise is a repeatable
set of tasks seriously defy
proficiencyright
and a task is an execution of a skill
and a skill
play I like actions right
and I still a set of actions
organized to produce
specific result nice place for this equate
to my functions.
Ayo
say if we compare
I really just really humans here
in fact several tracked correlations in
terminology
can be made Tweenies
terms and programme
so you could say up your burger is it going
to recur
so I can say an action is a statement
and I mean
askill okay
I think I got a lot of this photo to
cereal
I should hate you both
where do you have a skill
a skill is akin to a procedure not a
function
so a task is
a procedure called with arguments
exercise
I think it's a troll probably
Etsy hell to exercise what is exercise is
that's kind of a attest ribbon stuff right
can we find that matches at repeatable
combination
all skills
and exercise is the
pacification of
several
a group of tasks designed to solidify
learning true repetition
don't do that
I still see his memory of how to do a
certain set of tasks well
description would be a specific set of
actions to produce a result
yep well that's what a skill is
memory of how to do a certain set of tasks
well
yep still as still as the coating is the
coding
to do a thing a task and a task is doing the
thing
yeah if you if you if you go while I pursue
a covid
so the reason that
I finally concluded that it's killing a
tasker at the same level of scope
is because they both can be broken down and
both can be broken down into actions into
other
Skillet yeah yeah it's still as still as the
implementation of
strictly speaking a skill is does not tell
you how to do it
this is important so the skill would be
set up an NFS server right
it doesn't tell you how to set up an FS
server it just says you need to set up an FS
server and that's an operation
a task
play FNAF SL
so since he's so procedures or Apparition
with framers so we're missing is the method
and this is a word that actually directly
translates
so you can have those say Lucy you have
roundhouse kick right now so you have a Kik
you can roundhouse kick you can front kick
there's a million ways to say you have walk
so walking toward of the ability but let's
say let's say walking was a mug let's say
walking was
a skill if walking is a skill
then the name of the scale would be walk and
maybe you know
the method of walking could be any number of
things and a task would be walk to the store
and then you would employ you would use your
walk skill it's actually a billy but you do
use a walk skill following the method that
you had implemented to do walk and then you
would go there and you did so there's so
that's yeah I'm getting it I'm getting out
of that we're getting it this
I have a stable That's My Method what do you
mean by that will that's my method of doing
whatever right
other skills so the
so the skill is akin to an operation it's
it's the top little thing
and an action is just doing something it's
not necessarily a skill but it is strictly
speaking if you could call it a skill as
well like
never take a bite from a fork that's a skill
and believe it or not those are skills that
are covered in like you know accessibility
called courses up like that they actually
consider those skills training like me no
motor skills are literally called motor
skills so
you know and those skills are composed of
actions like to take a bath with a fork in
me and you know that it's like lift up your
hand touched before to pick up the fork of
the field to Fork into the food and you move
it your all of those little tiny actions to
combine together to create a skill like you
know eat some seafood with a fork
and that's a skill so it has an instruction
set right
I think I think that's really what it is
give me the other questions everybody I'm
here for a May time as well so
exercise is kind of like a unit test yeah
that was the first thing that came to mind
was like a it's kind of like a unit test
type inquiring research in critical thinking
of those are all skills there's a there's a
critical thinking is a tough one though
there's a nebulous line between a skill and
an ability
and I have a really really hard time
distinguishing the to some of them are
really easy to distinguish those some
abilities are innate like your ability to
see you can't learn to see right that's not
something you can learn so and blue I mean
abilities are required for work then a
little left of the 300 lb right that's an
ability that you can obtain
and that's not necessarily a skeleton
ability that you can you can obtain there
are certain buildings you cannot obtain
though it's like I will never be a fighter
pilot there's no way because the occupation
of fighter pilot demands the ability to See
20/20 without correction
and users wasting for your practice surgery
and stuff like that but that bilities are
not things that you can easily change and
that would be a professional Sportsman right
so that's I really think it's important that
we distinguish between abilities and skills
there are some abilities so if something is
sometimes there's an ability that borders on
ask you don't like typing me a lot about her
20 words a minute
right is that a skill or is it an ability
you know what you don't have hands it's you
know dinner that's part of its inability you
can't you can't learn a skill if you don't
have the base of Billy so
you know using a keyboard for example that
would be an ability that's not a skill
you know I mean it so I know I'm getting
financing about this but this is the time to
be pedantic because we're producing a model
on which all of our other stuff is going to
be built and I want to get it right I'm
going to get right I've been I've been
stressing over this for years more of that
decade actually it's kind of nice to come
back to it
because if we cuz we we we want to fix
the ability for people to track their skills
and and
and and look up skills are required to
perform Church certain occupations which is
at the end of the day and occupation is just
a collection of skills knowledge and
abilities and that's that's the
specification of occupation it is what you
need to do for occupation and you should be
able to drill down and and look up labs for
all that stuff
I wish you nothing but knowledge here
ability
one or more actions that require
innate or
difficult to learn natural ability
seeing lifting 100 lb
walking
I think you need a Milanese to be listed
here just this is just a brainstorming
session right here
right I just bring some recession
I'm glad we did this comparison to software
that because of skill really isn't a skill
as it is the outer shell
and the method is the nitty gritty
and the task is a single execution of that
so
critical thinking is definitely important
absolutely
a scale really is DM specification
a predictable result
I'm giving a certain set of parameters can
include other skills
I definitely know that's what this is
Miss skill is the interface and the method
is the implementation of the interface and
just like in software development interfaces
are verbs
right I am thinking independently one of my
life with you
which is now in a very tiny one that in the
90s really
so the scale is the specification
predictable result
with requirements
play the measurable requirements
when provided with
specific parameters I'm going to say this
testable
it's a testable specification of a
predictable result with me with measurable
outcomes on Friday with specific parameters
without specifying how the result is to be
obtained
that's that is that Nails it that's exactly
what his skill is that's what his skill is
no details for the implementation
implementation is
our choice the reason is so important is
because as we specified skills we go through
labs and stuff they're going to be many ways
to fulfill that skill
and
my way is going to be different in your way
and you're going to make a write-up of how
you did it and how you accomplished it and
your way might be more efficient than my way
both of them get to the end right and
so to put their desires in a Wiki yes
absolutely and that that's you're basically
having them specify that
is the teaching is it just like you show me
telling what we need to learn to write like
you'd be with him giving a little task
feedback positive enforcement till I get to
as a means by mentor
he should be better is kind of expected of
you to know everything to be able to love
yourself yeah
yeah it is
well okay so did you fare there's actually
want to just when I've been making to the to
the to the Moose this year this is something
I've learned over the years particular since
these last two years as I start streaming
you started it with so many different people
is the beginner boost is going to be well I
put it this way
I call it phases
yeah you can call out hodgepodge
I mean you can call it bullshit whenever but
phases are stages and call it stages that
looks like last
so alright so
I really think that there are three
stages to learning there's preparation where
you need lots of hand-holding
yeah I see you on the stage exactly we
talked about that there's preparation and
that's where you have an intense amount of
hand-holding because people aren't used to
it and then you have programming which is
sort of a separate thing and then you have
projects is the main one in professional so
and I said I mean by that so I can few
projects you can do with others you can do
by yourself at the bottom line is you when
you first start out when you started helping
some people think of your mentoring you need
you need to kind of be there for them or you
need to let them up more and
that's that's what I'm going to try to do
with the universe
there's a there's one bit of tweaking I had
to do every year it's I've had to do more
and more hand-holding
proper planning and preparation prevents
piss-poor performance so so
and the problem with this is if you do if
you continue to hold their hand to the level
it when they first beginning they will never
learn to learn
so I might approach on that 27-piece my
Approach on this is that you should kind of
step back and
at some point you can stroll them do their
thing and that's where projects come in
right
so so yeah a boost to me is is handling and
we're going to hand hold your help your hand
hold your hand for the basic stuff and get
to get you excited about it and then
hopefully you pick it up and go off on your
own
is it one of the things that I struggle with
forever is teaching people how to learn I
think it's he will say hey go to college and
learn how to learn do you want you going to
college in the people who've already learned
how to learn to survive the rest dropout
and that's the problem and people have been
people you know say oh hey if you made it
through college you learn how to learn and
even if it was a liberal arts degree you're
going to be a great employee because you
went to college it's really unfair because
a lot of those people who didn't make it
through college never learned how to learn
or they did learn how to learn their work it
was an innate thing that's what Ken Robinson
says and it was beat out of them now so I
can Robinson's this and I never recovered it
which is a fucking tragedy actually is so
might I haven't figured out how to do this
other than to be available for people and to
elect them be free to explore and discover
their own method of learning at the problem
with you cannot you cannot write a book or
create a method that teaches people how to
learn you can't do it
because every single person learns
differently there are certain things in
common obviously
every single person learns differently and
I'm going to psych Ken Robinson on that
again
I'm going to say I can Robinson Ken Robinson
talks about you know that was her face so
you can graduate Art Academy she was failing
out of our school classes they put her in a
kinetic school dance school where people
moved around while they were doing their
math or whatever and she just took off
because the they let the learning
environment was adapted to the person
have to be in business yam so
and this is something I've struggled with
forever I think the natural it feels very
loose and disorganized when people came to
school sick because they come in and yes we
have you know lessons and stuff like that
and products that we work on together and
stuff but a lot of the people that are in
the in the room are not classroom Learners
and so some of the more I would stand back
and just say hey there's a project we're
working on this working at together we're
here to help you when they would do that
learning new stuff while yeah I kind of
think that's the reason we're alive first
lie
I think the reasons is this goal of life is
learning.
So it's easy for me to get religious sleeve
you know it feels spell softball about it
getting old score old holder nothing like
that
yeah right after dye yeah well that's life
I mean that's what nature is about prazosin
yeah
yeah it's so
but the hardest part really honestly the
hardest part is creating a system for
everybody to learn when every single person
is different I think trying to create a
single diet for All Humans
there's certain things that will kill some
people and that that and I'll make other
people very healthy just every single person
is different and we have to treat people as
individuals and organizing content in such a
with such you know reality is very hard it's
very very hard
and the best you can do is share things
that'll work for you and create a community
where people can discover other people who
have similar situations and follow on the
health parallel you know you have diabetics
and I made a community where is FODMAP
issues you know how
did you know on their intestinal tract works
if only somebody else become my support
group for you to go and switching you find
people that are obsessed with the terminal
if you like you don't learn command lines
and skills so I think the best way to go
forward is to create opportunities for
people through community
and then they can do the learning on their
own but the question originally was Will
what it what if you just get left on that in
the you know is teaching
showing and telling what they need to learn
learn to write or you like be with him give
him a little task feedback positive
enforcement till he gets it
buy mint Oreo it's also important to know
that I meant or is not a personal trainer
afraid you can do it that's that's not my
definition of mentor every single Mentor
however is different in every personality is
different than theirs drill sergeant Mentor
going to fucking yell in your face and spit
at you and then there's there's mention
they're going to give you a name an okay
let's try that you know they're going to
give you a hug after everything and there's
different types of mentors and personalities
and that's and learning styles and that's
why I think mentorship is so important
because you're going to you're going to
connect with another human who happens to
have the skills that you need and you're
going to learn from them and that's that's
mentorship that's what it is and trying to
say that all Mentor should be like this or
that is stupid because that's not how all
people are
and social aspect
like I'll do it so I got into the world and
trying to do it and there are some drop out
since you seen a little life it mean if your
hair but yeah that's what measuring is he
has are generally there to encourage you and
motivate you and help you answer your little
little problems ain't the first time people
hear about Metro they usually think of it
like a businessman torbett business mentors
are big right senior Executive Vice
Presidents and stuff like that and they
usually have a mentor somebody who's really
experienced and they're also in business and
they they go to him to give them their SOB
stories and and lean on them and they give
him the courage minutes and stuff like that
it's not like Yoda right then but there's
other measures that are more of a Toyota you
know Master roll
I try my best to teach him stuff what's that
now he has his own team yeah there you go
that's how it works is that humans have been
doing it since the dawn of time just before
we had the school's is before we had schools
this is how humans learn they were naturally
built to learn this way and to share our
learning with others you watch it says I saw
a documentary on something about the
swimming about the distinction between the
Animal Kingdom in humans and it made some
pretty strong comparisons before making a
distinction about about different species
and one of the things they show that just
blew me away was the primates teaching other
primates how to open coconuts and stuff like
that
and how do they do it they do it primates
teach each other and then they drew the
distinction that the reason that the
primates haven't exceeded our level of
intelligence is because of one thing the
ability to pass on generational knowledge
and record it so as soon as humans figured
out how to capture knowledge and writing
we fucking blew up we blew up
we blew up and we took over every other
thing level of intelligence because now it
was exponential now the learning from one
generation could pass on to the next
generation without them being there to show
them how to do it
and as soon as we invented writing as soon
as Humanity invented writing weed we just
took over we took over everything else but
before that and still today the learning
that happens is a very direct thing I give
you yours I just remember the scene it had
to primates I don't know what type of monkey
they were they were they were literally
showing each other how to do it there like
okay I'm going to do it now and then they
would stop and then the other one would take
it up birds do this to there's a there's a
particular bird
the particular bird that has to learn how to
sing to win over the girls
and it will have a mentor singer hang out
with him and then we'll also get a posse of
like a backup singers is the craziest there
is so much fun there's this this is if you
ever get a chance to look it up it's so
hilarious it's hilarious there's like a girl
bird and she's sitting there and the guy
bird comes up and he's like trying to court
her right and he'll have the Guyver the yeah
the guy version will have like a backup
singers that are there to help him and the
backup singers aren't there to get the girl
they're there to back him up so he's singing
and then the backup singers are helping him
saying but the backup singers are learning
how to sing it So eventually they're going
to be going to be the lead singers and their
own thing and so the Virgin is so fucking
occurred cute it's just for the music but
that Sound Nature passes on knowledge
Nature has been mentoring since nature
existed
this is how knowledge is passed on between
animals in the animal kingdom as well as
human indifference the only difference is
that we teach kids to ask your kid I was
like watching Jessica or whatever the
Russian yesterday and I are watching how the
Russians articulate the words they're not
thinking about what they're saying
they're just saying it because they have
been mimicking the people are around a fact
about Linguistics in the best way to get to
learn Linguistics is to immerse yourself why
because then you get to mimic everything
you're around all the people that you're
around your mimicking them and mimicking and
repetition is the way to learn that's the
that's the real way to learn that's how
humans I've been learning at our species any
species that passes on know and that's how
they do it
they don't have some fancy asks you how do
you write a constitution that you know it's
it's through its through mentorship and
mimicking an apprenticeship and and help me
that's how learning happens it always happen
it's the most natural way to do learning
through experimentation and through
mimicking and and being with somebody who
knows or something that knows
and so
the thing is great about that is it you can
always adapted to your needs monkey see
monkey do absolutely we laughing about this
but is totally true
when when you can basically throughout the
entire fucking formal academic institutions
of of the world and you can say actually all
you really need to do is do with the monkey
zoo
go tell go tell that to your theoretically
pedantic bombastic piece of shit overly
verbose professors in college go tell them
that you know what I can replace you with a
monkey
who actually knows how to do something
that's valuable that's going to get me some
food to eat
that's like the biggest insult ever
if anything the whole academic fuck up is is
the extreme end of what has made us Superior
to all the other species
Astoria it's made it so Superior to all the
other species is because
if you think about it what what was the
thing that first separated us
yeah
what was the thing that four separate is
from the other species as well according to
that one documentary the one thing was the
written word and generational learning
in terms of knowledge as to did the
knowledge and theory is I think that right
so I would go I would go so far as to say
that the written word was the invention of
theory
as soon as we started to be able to write
about things
the writing was no longer do this then do
this then do this it wasn't recipes for how
to do something like you would like it would
create if you were with the person or thing
it became hey and here's maybe why you're
doing this right and communicate yeah and so
I would say that writing was the beginning
of the end of Education because
it was also necessary obviously but the
extreme end of the ability to write is what
you get when you pay $80 for
for an academic text that you're forced to
buy by an academic who thinks that that's
the only way you should ever be and you
should pursue you should pursue just
academic learning theory as for the rest of
your life and that is the end goal and gives
a shit about her going to make money why
don't you go work at the restaurant while
you're you know studying these really
esoteric crazy ass things that are in this
$80 book that I forced you to buy
so it's like the opposite extreme is the
opposite of screaming obviously the solution
is somewhere in the middle you have to have
a certain amount of of reading and theory
and stuff like that combined with the
practical application of those things
against me
I'm reading writing is an extension World
communication but it is voice in your head
telling story absolutely and that's actually
how I like the right actually
US 22 is what are the most popular books
when when you when you need to learn
something fast
and it's a little dated and now but what was
the most popular technical book craze
what was it you guys remember
and heinous
and aren't xxs in 24 hours and here's
another series you guys remember this the
dummies series
remember the dummies series like Karate For
Dummies and and you know recipes for dummies
and pearl for dummies and
when was the dummies book why were the
dummies books so wildly successful
I'll tell you why Cliff Notes yeah XXX for
dummies and Cliff tells the reason they're
wildly successful is because they're
practical
they're totally practical
his books are popular because why is this
somebody was just saying that you see
writing is an extension of oral
communication will there you go there's the
proof in the pudding how many people go to
the Barnes & Noble bookstore wherever their
books or is and ask for an eighty-dollar
text book on data structures and algorithms
are there some good there's a definitely
good content about how many people go there
and get that
this is a good a good distinction to the
book I wrote data structures in C
throws out all that theory shit doesn't have
it in it and it's as much than her book and
it has just a practical application of data
structures and algorithms much better book
it feels to me more
and the Java for dummies
are is your processor absolutely yeah if you
if you if you read the dummies books what
are they
the most popular book series for O'Reilly in
the most popular book series among all those
other ones it's the recipe books
it's the recipe books and then do this and
then do this books and what are those this
is actually getting back to our turn the
terminology stuff because the books that
tell you how to do a thing
and a nice clear way are the most popular
because they give you skill they give you a
power they don't do your eyes about why it's
valuable
yeah they've changed a lot I know O'Reilly's
going downhill I'm not going to lie I agree
text message I got through college on Cliff
Notes I had a Russian major
did they assigned us the volume of
retreating in Russian that they assign is
our senior year there was no fucking way and
the professors knew we couldn't read it they
knew we couldn't really they signed it
anyway because it was on the given her
credit a she made him look good it was like
it was like a dirty little secret that
nobody was going to ever read a thousands
and thousands of pages that they gave us no
one was going to be able to read it and no
one talked about it and they make sure
people got to use anyway but you know it was
all kinds of you know ways to survive that
had nothing to do with it
and it was just it was disastrous I know we
would have a conversation about it and then
they would did that the professor to make
sure to tell us about the stuff we were
going to talk about they say okay we're
going to talk about this so that we can read
at least that so the class was not a
complete waste so we can read that lease
that part most of the people by the time
they were seniors and Russian part part
cookie the fucking read Russian they still
can read it there's t-shirts in Russian and
they couldn't read you know Russia in and
then when you know because I need a ride or
whatever it is War and Peace
Warren peace because Anya I can remember
what you mean yeah. It was just it was
terrifying so
YouTube is educational. Yeah I think yeah
yeah
yeah I got no see no educational content on
YouTube definitely taking a text to cut up a
notch and lots of space Khan Academy right
I really just like button has been
tremendous how can I sell people been
complaining about that but I don't know why
what's up
I've seen several Bosch books bash things
lately
and I can't approve any of them so far other
than the bash main page
it does look pretty good though and the
primary expense is missing a ton of stuff
yeah the single brackets and that would make
me throw it out the fucking window
immediately
I would never use this it's missing really
basic stuff
is it just makes me so I got to do about
book I have to do bad content and we're
going to go to the bathroom and now so
people can see why this is so bad if you
ever use single brackets and Bash you are
feeling
I'm sorry I'm going to say it you can hate
me for saying so it's true single single
brackets and Bash well-supported are fucking
unnecessarily dangerous if you don't know
why go learn why
I know it's not in Bosch but yeah that's an
it's one of the most misunderstood things in
all of shell scripting
that Chelsea is pretty good
yeah if you do single brackets they're
totally bad do the research and understand
the difference I'm not going to tell you why
but the short answer is the single brackets
Dukes could do expansion that the gloves
start mansion and double brackets do not
which is why double brackets can contain
regular expression matches without any
quoting
strictly speaking you don't need to do a lot
of quoting in double brackets you still need
to when you have a variable that you're
going to be matching
and by the way if you can get away with it
if you're doing if you drink numeric
comparison you shouldn't be doing double
brackets either you should be doing double
parentheses because it forces everything
into an American text
and that's even safer
how many when's the last time you saw
anybody actually use double parentheses I do
bass change last time but it's not a bad
stream if you want to learn bass just go to
the main page and do what it says
I try to be mean that's just that's just
Nobody Does it
nobody doesn't there's tons of like really
unsafe reduction coaches great if your
hacker oh my God
Coronavirus
show us in Discord why what's going on
something bad happening
I know this is been a lot more commenting
lately or am I missing
you want to ask a question of the stage or
on the stage and I can't see you you're such
a raise your hand
oh you going to Henry sorry yes please
invite to speak
sorry I missed you hi there
is my voice yeah that sounds really great to
me probably for everybody else but sounds
great
yeah you're fine it's it's on my side I have
I have to adjust volume to seven you're good
what kind of certificate authorities would
you select
Handel soul in the hole. Oh I think that's a
great question and I don't have an answer
yeah yeah
absolutely yeah I just wanted to say that I
was just thinking about this
knowing about certificates just so nobody
else is listening and knowing about
certificates is a core infrastructure
engineering skill today and it's not it's
not just for web server is micro Services
any more certificates are used everywhere
and if you don't know about them and I don't
know the last time I did anything with
certificates was in my garden 97h and
actually you know we went to verisign and we
had to apply to get a certificate and it
took forever I noticed this when I started
doing Cube ATM for kubernetes it creates a
plethora mean how many certificates for you
and we've been burned by having certificates
expire tributaries because we didn't manage
certificates internally and then there's the
question of what when when do you use a
self-signed certificate do you use a
certificate across your entire Enterprise a
certificate
have you know these things like associations
parent-child kind of things and they
ultimately have is a CA like he's asking
about and the truth is I don't have a handle
on it right now I I have a general idea of
what certificates are used for and how they
they're issued and what a c a is and all
that but but when it comes down to best
practices for managing time or making your
own I feel really messy on that front I
don't I honestly don't have you know I'm it
and then there's the whole problem will do
you trust your ca at all
right what's what series do you use
sure
and McKnight let me turn my music down okay
yeah
I do know of it it's been a long time since
I worked with it you're talking about just
general DNS yeah
yeah no
I want to try yeah
how can you read to me yeah
completely supported check
take me there on Denison
yeah
where is area code for a certificate
Authority and how can you know that this
wasn't too many too late for drinking like
that
how can I go to a dealership with the main
thing is I can somehow use Affliction as a
way to receive
now
is completely well
that's that's amazing yeah that's been
needed that hasn't needed to be fixed for so
long
yeah
yeah because you could just use the same I
mean I know people use DNS for validation of
other things like like email right so
there's all kinds of extra DNS text records
that people have now for validating you know
email and email providers but I'm not aware
of anything until now that validates the DNS
query itself to make sure it hasn't been
messed with
yeah s p f n t x e but that's that's that's
always been a problem with Tony what Tony
fall is here Tony has talked about this
problem before
DNS maybe that's it a good use of blockchain
I don't know I wonder
absolutely
yeah and I think that's fine as is yeah I
don't know if we I would really like to see
the numbers on what if every single DNS
query in the world use this technology what
would that do what would the impact be if
literally every web request use this
yeah him
what you're doing right now
if you are to the right certificates that is
used to write it's not miss you as though it
has been expired and it's not the right to
me
interesting
that is so cool I really like it I mean we
need more people thinking about how to fix
the in us for sure that's Remains the single
point of failure for most major hacks you
know
I can take it over is that that's that's
super interesting you provided a link to
that so can we can go look at it read about
it
I just finished LOL
yeah
yeah I think you should probably should
definitely bounce that off Tony fought who
is spent a lot of time researching the the
the the security space for that also they
specifically mentioned DNS in some of the
work that they're doing so and Shake uses
concept it's proof on the Block chain for a
t l d and you can create as many shelters as
you want with auctions interesting
I ain't heard of that one yeah
yeah
had to come up with anything in this rain
certificate
yeah
I guess that would be that would be your you
whatever your
was it time to live you have to figure a way
to bust the cash that's still a problem with
DNS today right is the records take so long
to update but but they are cashed though so
so the blockchain wouldn't be bringing any
overly
I wouldn't add latency because most of DNS
transactions are cashed so that one time you
would have to get it a new one it would it
would be slower but how much more so I don't
know I'll be adventurous things to see
Hanson
yeah
you can have this we can use this with it's
been over to connect them secure and you
don't have to break a chain of trust and
it's very cheap rent
yeah yeah that yeah I mean if you could if
you can figure out some way to
I don't know I got to
the abstract the communication so that use
blockchain as a method of distribution as
you said and allowed another method of
distribution as well you know some people
can adapt but I don't know that that's
that's very very ambitious This Is Us
awesome to think about
the infrastructure problem which
infrastructure problem
yes right
him how would you know that they be honest
is writing to that quiet certificate
yeah
however I do I hope yeah well God knows we
need that we need to get off the certificate
authorities that has to be
a tie-dye book I agree I think that's a
problem be saying that we have that's always
been a problem by the way you know when
verisign it was the Monopoly in the universe
in the 90s and nobody got a certificate
unless you bow down and paid your $600 and
beg them to give you a certificate you
didn't get one and we do have you know free
let's encrypt
and things like that for but do we want to
trust them you know I don't know
hey I don't know how you can get rid of that
problem of trust
and shakes all this is well at the bar chain
Indiana sec
interesting building a secure website on
your handshake tell d interesting
I haven't read about this at all yet
if you never lost a website on a legacy
internet the process like this search for
available memorable name on Cotati and rent
it from the movie girls if you're getting a
DNS off GoDaddy you are doing it wrong I'm
just going to tell you right now I'm I know
GoDaddy I'm going to try to avoid a side
tangent but I know I'm GoDaddy literally
taking people's domains hostage they are
like the mafia of DNS people ocean droplet
named chief is better than they're getting
kind of bad joker was the one I've always
loved their from Germany
ocean droplet other cloud service and get an
IP address
go to go there and pay c i p go to server
and let's encrypt to assert bought which is
what I do I set up Apache
your demesne and SSL certificate from sef4
don't really belong to you
both assets can be revoked at any time and
have by the way this is why I used to buy
stuff from from Germany and Joker. Com
they didn't have a history of turning over
to main ownership without asking to America
and other authorities both digital assets
can be revoked anytime
I see you I just need a house reference
interesting
the Legacy process also conceals a lot of
the DNS stuff that is actually required
entrust them to host your name server for
your records fuck no I don't do that and a
handshake I don't do that I put my
nameservers someplace else I always do that
handshake replaces DNS and Trust
proof-of-work secures our relationship
between the domain name and the two
important sounds like you're doing something
somewhere
it is yeah it's ya the name server lives at
that IP address and serves as soon as dating
yeah I mean I think people need to
understand this Adam a name can be
confiscated by your country anytime they
want and they can take over everything they
can take over all your traffic and
everything you do if
yes oh my God yes
control the whole movie oh wow absolutely
yeah
so
yes yep that is totally true
that is totally true and if teas are yeah
it's the scarcity in the control that makes
it so valuable insane and that's why people
sit on them to sell them because they
WhatsApp
oh well
now wow that this is this is a big deal
yeah this at this DNS stuff is I think it's
one of the last pieces you know
of that of the old internet to really be
revised that needs some work like important
work so
what are you aware of any other solutions
that are not black chain-related I'm just
curious you know how I feel about crypto but
this is this is a good example of blockchain
technology that could be used for something
besides Krypto and some reason I believe we
still need to allow in on blockchain
Research to happen because there's many
other possibilities here soon
you have been thinking of you guys in school
Pensacola
connect me with some stuff together on the
internet
so
oh
yeah
yeah I know yeah yeah
I was just going to say the problem you
talked about is
I think what you're saying is that it's much
bigger than just DNS and this I think
carries into the conversation about zero
trust architecture a little bit because
you can't really trust anything how can you
trust any device right
and
yeah the only got ya they found those back
towards they found the back doors in the GPS
as well that were bad and supply-chain
problems in China and they were getting
modified before they were shipping
so yeah yeah
now
she has some kind of History
oh that's a good point
I want to capitalize on that idea for a
second so
you said something that I think is really
important so
and I'm just been dabbling in in not
blockchain but the idea of zero trust and
from what I understand about zero trust and
boils down to giving everything and a
verifiable identity usually through some
sort of cryptography but what you're
suggesting the blockchain offers is another
layer of that which is super interesting and
that is not just verifying identity but
providing a history for that identity and
that makes it so Amy just knowing something
came from who you said it was his one
problem but knowing that you can trust that
unique identity is a different question and
you can't really make that decision
yeah I mean as many difficulties in making
that decision right you have that you can
create a ring of trust like hey at least 10
other people also trust is so I'm going to
trust it but something that could contribute
to that even if it adds overhead would be
but let's look at the history of this thing
and let's decide if we can trust it all by
yourself and and that's something by Shane
doesn't bring to the table so because I mean
yeah I I just every time we talk about
watching it always I always get hung up on
the finite nature of the chain itself
no
get down yeah yeah
documents
yeah my friend my friend who does
presentations on this that that's the single
biggest compelling part of all of it to me
and then he calls it self Sovereign identity
and identity is the idea that that you own
your identity whether it be medical records
or you know business information or visit
the building blocks of zero trust
architecture you know it's it it stands on
its own you're right and that that I think I
want to believe in that but I I sometimes
feel like I don't know I feel like it's just
too perfect
I was just going to keep up with the work
it's not right
the problem is because they use because the
the way that smart contracts
all right yeah yeah
yeah
yeah and I am wanted to I wanted so hard to
like ethereum in distributed apps and then I
saw how permanent the contracts were and
that was hard
but yeah I mean
industry is filled with the idea gets which
yeah
it'll make things very fast it doesn't he
must watch this channel you know that I
talked to him about that all the time yeah
all right
what's up right now
yeah
are we this is a this is there's actually a
guy who gave a presentation on this and he
did you use an American reference he did a
War of the Worlds scenario where what if
Google went down and he painted a picture is
a fictional picture of the like there's like
I think six people at Google wear if if if
more than half of them were unavailable the
whole world would stop Gmail I go at cuz cuz
things will go down you know and yeah so I
think you're making a point about
centralization bad
yeah hey Ya
so this problem.
Yeah yeah yeah
just people rely on as an identity as a
money
if it went down yeah yeah
no
beat correct yes yeah I know I think that's
the darphin it was in the military angle
they said make a network that will survive a
nuclear bomb and therefore DNS is
distributed that's another problem with the
NS by the way Federation yeah DNS has been
so screwed up because everybody uses Cloud
fair for their DNS and it went down in the
whole half the internet went down and I
don't know why we're not learning this this
I don't know I don't know why we're not
picking up on this and doing something
better you know thinking about it
him
yeah
Pax Rich's right
the function I'm sorry functional
programming
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
transaction outfits or which one are you
talking about
isn't
okay yeah I didn't
I don't think I realized that difference
between the two so wait let me restate this
so you're saying that Bitcoin partially
succeeded because it had an unlimited scope
you know it wasn't limited and then admitted
but that if they're e m got limited because
I had a global and try to have a global
state is that right is right and interesting
yeah
yeah I don't I think it was a cash yeah
you're going to look at
if you're trying to split them and you can
take them to a one or two catches and give
them to a Smart contract it can take the
other caches and give them to 1%
to basically
yeah well yeah I should probably look at
that again and go back to it and just give
it a fresh
can different action has five types of body
okay
yeah
from 1 to 1 minutes one and it can be can be
at this address
which one are you describing I'm sorry which
one you just driving right now
okay
maybe it's a surface that emits for me
become the bridge
because if you can make something that's why
I'm really you know I have two two things
that I I really want to follow with regard
to manipulate I like the the d-pad breakdown
of how it works it's super interesting I
feel like I need to get makes me want to get
back into a little bit but there's two
things virtual welcome Tony Faso tell me if
I was here so I spell persist in talking
about some some possible
you know alternatives to DNS that depend on
blockchain technology to to allow you know
to remove the requirement to trust a single
CA in which inflates prices on DNS and all
that kind of thing and didn't come here to
the question just about boxing in general I
have I have their stuff three questions that
I still have with regard to crypto and I
think they're pretty mainstream questions
the first one is what is the impact of the
51% attack and the reality of it and there's
good and there's good you know educated
people who still feel like that
undermines the entire mathematical approach
completely let alone how it's deployed in
the second what is the movement towards
proof of stake versus proof of work is so
that we can eliminate the impact on the
world for for a technology that's so
competition Ali intense
and I know that is always kind of a third
thing I'm like why can't we just use gpg I
know what you could just got on the tations
because they're
you know is there something else is the
three things that I had those kind of my
mind we talking about Frank Russian
government might be might ban Bitcoin mining
completely
Oggi's how to get a band that I'm going to
try and attract all the transactions I guess
it would
I'm anxious to know how if know if house
looking like I should prefer that you want
for some tacos accurate yeah I am a sentient
being is real and it is and if it's a thing
if it's a thing I'm not saying it is but I
believe it is because I trust the people
that I've asked you've done PhD
dissertations on this Brian Ford comes to
mind the guy who invented Peg and I I don't
know is if it if it is a thing and that
means it is possible for someone to gain
full control of the entire blockchain
it is possible under certain conditions at
the fact that it's even possible I I don't
want that to sound like Fudd you know I'm
not spreading fear just for the fear sake I
truly want to understand it because
otherwise it could be a very strong enough
solution to problems like DNS and other
stuff so my niece is attractive swallow a
pill it's like growing weed and and crypto
mining
do you have a lot of you have a lot of Sun
lamps in your house or do you have a lot of
servers either way what if you have both I'm
growing weed and I'm doing crypto mining
so they're still trust most watching over
Facebook server Farm yeah
yeah you sure can I might have to walk away
for a second my wife is here but if you want
it if you want it hold on to the Miken and
answer questions for people I'm happy to let
you do that just be nice to people if you
want to join the conversation you can I'm
going to walk away from about 5 minutes so I
take a break but
but yeah sure certainly you're certainly
welcome what's up
I can still kind of hear you at least I
could
needs a big players 1% big Wells Will
control most of the decisions and it work
yeah
mobile
I am going to take a break I'm just going to
step away
step away for about 5-10 minutes so the
Discord is is up and you're welcome to
continue to answer questions from the chat
sounds like you know a lot about this topic
so if you would like to answer questions
from the chat while I'm away for 5 minutes
or so that be great so I'll head over to
I don't know if they like it or not they're
going to do it anyway
because it's great to have somebody who's
got the level of knowledge you have with us
and and I'll be back
I'm back what I miss my my wife is
my wife is buying a car so I'm trying to
help her
Amazon wallets that's a good question hey
thanks for the gift Subs people
old etherium classic anymore
that wasn't like it's not anything like the
the Bitcoin and Bitcoin cash or something
yeah oh God
wow yeah
now wow
yeah yeah yeah there's actually a really
good documentary about this I think it's on
Amazon Prime I thought it was going to be
kind of one-sided and they kind of walk the
middle path I forget the name of it if
anybody remembers it actually takes you on
tour through the like these facilities in
New Zealand in the Netherlands and and
Iceland that are doing Bitcoin and stuff in
it you know was It was kind of an eye-opener
I talked about some of the good things you
can do until the bad
but but yeah
the questions I have
yeah I have three by three of the three
questions that I have about any box and
Technology you know what the obvious ones
right the the power consumption and proof of
stake versus proof-of-work possibilities
going for the most substantial question I
have is is the math sound and sustainable
and I I feel like that the 51% attack has
been downplayed by the entire crypto world
without the blockchain the 51% attack is not
an issue for banks doing bank-to-bank
exchanges because they you know they they
control everything they can probably do
proof of stake and so using blockchain
technology in an isolated controlled
environment makes sense but when you start
to go out there in the whole point of black
Santa supposed to be zero trust
and if you you can't have zero trust if
there's a possibility that someone is going
to have 51% control
51% control eventually and I I don't I'm a
I'm a novice and understanding all of us but
I've asked people and it so that's that's my
biggest my biggest concern is it that it's
at the actual math of the entire thing is is
it's founded on the hope that nobody will
ever have 51% control
and that's that's the main one and
I don't know if that's the way to talk about
it what's up coming here makes easy work
do another question yeah go ahead and repeat
alright
yeah I guess
what's up I'm not going to blow your mind
as engines
all the users of the spine of books what's a
51% attack
now
even keep going to because Europe
Mom I'm in the different rhyme
right
we will be able to do is just
yeah they couldn't they they couldn't alter
transactions they could stop transactions
and they couldn't reverse transactions
either right
yeah it's impossible to reverse a
transaction yeah it's not like if they get
51% I think that's the I'm glad you said
that because that's important people know
if somebody could can get could get control
I'm in theoretically theoretically someone
could get control of the entire blockchain
but they could never steal
from people that have already done whatever
the transaction is they couldn't steal that
nor could they they could just shut it down
right they could say hey we're not going to
let these other people participate in the
mining and
yeah right so they would just make their own
and that yeah
right and I what's at the Hatchery what's at
the Hatchery is what
speed of conversations that Hatchery so and
then at the other the other big I'm sorry go
ahead
yeah yeah yeah oh yeah
yeah there's just I really think that we
need to consider keep practising as Society
in general needs to keep experimenting with
blockchain tech I really believe that I
don't want anybody to get the wrong
impression and I've. Talk to you about my
annoyance about people trying to save the
world with blockchain instead of spending
time doing other things that's more of a
social problem and not so much a tech
problem
and but and it's been in there the energy
thing and you know I heard extra first time
I heard it was on go time is it Go Time
Podcast and add somebody on there and they
talked about I talk about proof of stake and
if we can do proof of stake and have it be
safe I'm not convinced proof of stake isn't
just a different form of CGA you know what
do you think of that
right
yeah
yeah yeah that's true
wow I hadn't even thought of that that is
that is a really good point maybe it is it's
really energy-intensive and people usually
talk about how that's bad for the
environment and stuff but I hadn't even
thought of it as being the point of failure
you pull a plug of the energy to a farm and
goodbye in us and governments do control
energy consumption
yes
well I think that's why people of Iceland so
much Iceland is so free as some of the
biggest farms I heard her in Iceland not for
the sun energy but because of the lack of
Regulation and the other I love of the
finance industry in general ever die so just
like
what do you think about
yeah
right and I forgot about geothermal in
Iceland that's a big deal that is a big deal
in general energy yeah South Dakota
right
yeah
but I don't want my only problem with proof
of stake as I understand it is I know it's a
different technology but
it would be getting the buy-in on the ring a
trust kind of idea you no proof of stake
doesn't work unless a group of minnow
participants agree that these people matter
more than other people are already know that
mean I'm paraphrasing but
rap
sphere volume yeah
first of all do not give it to any job give
it to any tricks easy right
yeah
right now
yeah yeah I can see a lot of a lot of ways
that would be okay
now
no not really no not in this says snow now
you don't care no
yeah
you can
yeah I have to play Devil's Advocate though
because I
I mean proof of stake to me
kind of rolls back one of the main
advantages of blockchain
which is you know absolute decentralisation
and
while I think proof-of-stake still
distributes the authority to more people in
ass people talk about academics or however
you want to do it or like you say with your
competitors with multiple networks even
though it it opens the doors for 4:40
centralization it's still to some degree
centralized and then you have to ask
yourself is all of this technology necessary
or could we just look at another way of
decentralized thing you see anything cuz as
soon as you start rolling back the I think
is the primary argument for blockchain which
is decentralisation
then you know it's it's i h developer you
know I feel like you know is it still worth
all the
yeah
is that
I'm going to help provide
help them
helps poor people like that
interesting
oh wow that that I don't think I realize
that that steak is transferable obviously
because it's just an identity at the end of
the day
yeah
it makes you wonder though if that if
there's like a shadow Market
that would emerge to sell steak you like
if it couldn't happen I mean could it happen
I mean
oh okay
oh I see I see what you're saying
I see
so you're saying you're saying that the
participants in the chain itself can choose
to say so basically Blacklist certain steak
and to go now we're not doing it and that's
interesting because I think it with that who
it was that we said the whole box anything
assigned for a second and I want to talk a
little bit about how I've been trying to
establish knowledge trust you know on their
knowledge exchange grid it boils down to Oki
and it's a whole circle of trust thing but
that includes blackballing people are
blacklisting people it's like I I trust you
so I want to hear everything you have to say
and I want to hear who you trust to get
information from and I also want to hear who
you don't trust to get information from and
so on and so on and you you build a
community ring of trust that I would really
like to see happen in terms of just
Knowledge Management I want to see
everything then.
If I says I know and I don't want to see
anything that so-and-so says so
if those principles are applied to the
blockchain and proof of stake and it sounds
like they are then I think it's based on
solid principles even if
another lot lot of that stuff is yet to be
yeah
absolutely and I'm all about finding ways to
do that and and that's another reason I just
want to say another reason that I'm even
talking about blockchain and stuff like that
is because
because something in this conversation is
going to fix the centralization problem in
our world today it's going to fix it and
there's I believe strongly that I don't know
that we're there yet but I something that's
coming out of this science
it's going to fix that and it's going to be
big
no it hasn't
yeah yep
yeah right
yeah
yeah yeah I mean there's we've tried this
before I just soon as I feel like some of
the other distributed decentralisation
Technologies are not being like you just
stay just like basic Pierce or a to Pyramid
now working without you know the need for
the blockchain I sometimes wonder if that
some of those Technologies could be
I mean if you were if you if you eliminate
the need to have to trust everything so why
can't we just focus on like things on this
is like really naive idea but the
cypherpunks were all about encrypting
content and and then you know you just
distributed content however you want it you
didn't care about the method of Transport or
decentralisation the content was guaranteed
to be signed and athletic aided by a
particular key and if a key was validated
you could you know if he was bad you could
you could never just sitting there was a
central place to put keys but it could be
anywhere and then the owner of the key cuz I
hate this Keys been retracted or whatever so
anyway what is Frank saying the defensive
approach
for your sake has attack vectors according
to PDF
if the following barriers to longest chain
proof of State protocols that's interesting
paper
did you see this one that sounds
well what is cryptocurrency
yeah if you want any links to anybody wants
to put in the chat and some people can do
their own research on this
alright I've actually heard about this when
I pretty sure I'm pretty sure I've heard
about this one
sure
what will happen to these people
and they are very valuable people can just
exist yeah
leaders of the world
become comfortable with our technology so
that we can help you in all these things
and those two things on it and you can put
it into the other two
a romantic country
controversial things to tend to exert of
preserved forever yeah they're going to be
there and then I can send to the zero trust
me we have done if I here again we were
talking about earlier about zero trust and
how I mean that we weren't specifically
saying about how blockchain could be used to
deploy as reference architectures but I'm
interested to see what technology comes out
of the zero trust architecture movement that
could be used alternatively 4D
centralization in place of blockchain or in
tandem with blockchain
have to wind it once the book is generated
it has to be it has to be sent to the hole
Miss World like to like 95% of the network
in under five seconds
the security assumptions and that's very
critical by the way but
establish a single point of Truth and he can
take any amount of operators from this
protocol and establish your own size
LOL
yeah wow yeah that's it is
it is this it is and that's it does it just
blows my mind how how efficient all of this
stuff is you know even if it takes 30
minutes to buy a pizza with Bitcoin you know
brushing technology depending on how it
support can be done efficiently and the
proof of stake thing is proving that more
I'm just excited to see what happens I a boy
but when you think about the 4th generation
yeah
yeah I mean is it is it allows people yeah
the practical
right
yeah I'm super excited by where it's going I
just the Practical you know guy cynic in me
remains this is like you know the old dude
in me it just
the level of complexity we tried to do an
ethereum contract as this as a as a camp
once and the level of potential risk key
points of failure during the development
process this is if there is some kind of
picking on the whole thing it's not fair to
pick on the whole thing just because of the
ethereum contract
but I bet it it makes a larger point and the
larger point is the layers of complexity
that this has everything and then isn't
Justified so in the 1990s we live in a world
where nothing was encrypted tell that fdp
mail everything travel over the wire and
absolute clear text and things were simpler
in it and if if we go back to that
go back to that time of a simpler time right
and also like a fucking crazy insecure time
too and it was no chance of ever getting you
know people are doing credit card
transactions in the clear over the over the
internet at the time and then and then what
and then we have you know the old school
days of like one server multiple users you
know NFS and then I asked and then came
virtualization and things got more
complicated and then came containerization
and things got more Camp complicated but as
soon as you start to imagine a world where
we're combining containerization with no
orchestration like everybody's and things
like that with watching Tech you're starting
to reach a level of complexity that a guy
like me has to ask why you know why are we
we doing this are there are there are
simpler ways of going about this and I'm I'm
not attacking it I think it needs to be
dealt with and we need to explore it just
like
kubernetes to be dealt with. I'm still not
100% convinced that the jury is completely
you know decided that Cooper Nettie's is
going to be the way to go for the whole
future I think it's probably about 80% or
90% I go for that but I've seen Technologies
coming fail and come and go and come and go
in and obviously blockchain Tech is not
going anywhere there's so much money
invested it at this point I like Peach p b
there is an entire economy surrounding it so
it's going to be with us forever but it is
it is it the best thing for us is it going
to be a minute if we're going to add
yeah it's Emily different I think the bottom
line is
are the benefits going to outweigh the
negatives and Anna and that's a really basic
thing to say but
yeah
yeah yeah
if you right
blockchain
became possible
if there's a trust going to be
okay well V symbol yeah
I know. That is why I see what you're saying
that that is definitely value it's very hard
to quantify that value though because you
know every scientific lie anyway it may be
absolutely right I mean is it going to be
going to be less
you know that the technology is going to is
going to replace a bunch of other systems
that people use that same argument for the
web and they were right I remember a guy
named Don Tapscott predicting the removal of
the middle layers of society and economies
and now after Covetous hit I mean let's
let's be real it's all about bosses and
people working for bosses and the people in
the middle are largely eliminated even Banks
of centralized because so much of the
competition has been replaced by stuff that
can be provided in this you know the zero
opportunity cost sharing economy that were
in you know it's things like this I can come
to y'all directly right and the building so
the point being
yes Technologies in the past have
fundamentally change the social fabric at
the economic level as well and they have
clearly Justified their costs was just stick
with webtech is as much as I complain about
how horrible the web is now
what is now you know technology has paid for
itself I mean you can make the same argument
against the internet right so they give all
those extra server Farms right
yeah yeah and so so I guess I'm agreeing is
that it is possible that it it is possible
that this technology will alter Society in a
way that pays for the technological
innovation as we have seen the internet do
the internet has clearly paid for itself you
know all of the money necessary to deploy
the internet as we know it today and believe
me I mean a trillions of trillions of
dollars to do it I think has easily been
you know one back by the value it is
provided the whole world and so I think it's
safe to say that that bunting or
Technologies like it could could eventually
have a return on investment that is equal to
what the internet gave us it's just hard to
know that right now Steve Jobs had to go to
work what's up
yeah you can certainly do I mean there's a
lot of people who can help us understand
it's like Steve Jobs trying to describe
describe two I kind of like listening to you
talk to me it's it's like Steve Job there's
a there's a video of him trying to explain
to the common person why you would ever want
to connect two computers together
he's like no really if you connect two
computers you can have this in this and he
sounds just like a block chain person you
know he's like trying to sell sell the idea
that we understand the whole world will
change everything is going to pay for it so
why would I pay to connect my computer as
its insecure it's a bad thing it's going to
cost us more money all the same arguments
against blockchain
we're against networking computers and look
where that went you know
right
help people
even if you have the STI in the world
oh right yes it was really fun
yeah this true it would be great if we had a
better way yeah
yes
we do and I've had plenty of bad things make
it into my mind so yeah
look at the social media
but then clicks on what you're sharing is
better
right
the husband actually has two cases Facebook
for example must was arguing think or that's
ridiculous
Facebook login
we don't need fact checkers
Snopes yeah
but that my my my stepson was just telling
me that about the Flat Earth people
and they they were there you cannot convince
them and I don't want to die over to into
that but you just cannot convince them of
the fax is there that's physically they just
will not accept it under any circumstance so
yeah people are going to make their own
reality but Sciences
always been the best and we need to protect
ourselves from that until I guess your point
is
something like a blockchain could protect us
from our own wrong conclusions that might be
based on
false false intuition things like that yeah
fuchsia
I would love to have an option what I can
share with
or anyone who's Express in the field can you
please help me verify this
huh wow
yeah
and you can see a completely different about
one topic and can
yeah I can't wait to yeah I would prefer
that I yeah I mean I'm all about creating
Circles of people that I trust and picking
the people that I trust and I realize
there's a danger they're creating an echo
chamber of people that only tell you what
you believe I mean that's that's you know
what others have suggested as you have
gotten us into this problem in the past is
now being able to check our own intuition
but yeah those are those are crazy topics
really fun topics aren't they
I need a Dutch coin Echo chamber
Bible say everyone Frank I think yes Frank I
think you mean a Taurus
I sorry I had to put that in there they're
talkin about flat earthers now
is the island where the tourist was in
Second Life cuz it was like one of the
friends that you can do for modeling
I was just before I interact with but I'm
not opposed to disagree with each other I
think I think having control of your sources
of input is a fundamental human right eye I
believe that wholeheartedly and I thought I
believe that there's a lot of these searches
are violating that by taking that away from
us and guessing what we want and I think we
should be able to control our search
the control our search engine optimization
ourselves we should be able to say this is
what I want to search for this is what I
want you to show me and they refuse to do
that so
basically make this a green
no no I can't I agree that's why we need
something more and that that leads into what
I loved it in my favorite topic that I don't
do anything with which is the whole you no
idea of exchanging like what time you want
us using 24 hours using a metal casting now
on and I'm able to read those thoughts
directly it's much more than just a block
Network by the way it's it's it's being able
to see people don't think about things in
real time and what are they how are they
digesting you know their thoughts is that if
they choose to publish them let me know the
people that want to do that but but yeah but
it wasn't very I haven't played in a long
time have any other questions from the from
the peanut gallery
it's been a sufficient time since I drink my
coffee to require that I take another break
for reasons that I shall not say but I I
think
but this is been a phenomenal conversation
developer II still alright I appreciate it
so much it's it's you know it says
yeah I mean it's I like being able to play
around with these ideas and you know how
people in an attack our own biases and stuff
like that one video we need to get that box
chain really end tables and a new human
interactions the history of get get him in
coinbase interesting to consider it
absolutely and and that's you know I don't I
don't I don't I don't know either I mean.
You're my Still Remains you know reasonably
skeptical of
an excruciatingly large amount of technology
to accomplish things that might be
accomplished with a better phone system you
know or or is it my criticism of the crypt
the world in general is that they they keep
siding you know World change in the
illumination of poverty in the New World
Order and all this and they don't look at
other simpler methods to accomplish those
goals microloans and we should also print
off work and everything like that so I don't
want to say we don't need no stinking
internet who needs an internet we don't need
our computers connected together there's no
reason that we should ever have that mean
that could have been somebody in the 1980s
saying the same thing I don't want to be
that guy I want to allow the exploration
even if I don't understand its value
directly yet and and that I have continued
to try to understand that value and having
having somebody like you know
eyedropper here are my other friend who is
he and I had extensive talks about this is
that we hear it out and believe it or not I
do believe that about rust to I still want
to hear them out I'm going to laugh at them
every time you make a mistake but but I
think that we need to hear out new
technologies and allow them to the professor
something Xavier nipped in the bud and just
destroyed immediately like like what
documentation they require JavaScript
but this is really great to have this
conversation I'm going to go ahead and step
away again again I just want to thank you
for the offer for all of that
I'm I'm actually going to move on to a
different topic here and I'm probably going
to if somebody has a new question I want to
be able to allow other people to come in and
call it does anybody else he wants to call
in I'll still be here I'm going to be
turning back to the some of the Knowledge
Management stuff for the beginner boost but
I find this extremely fascinating stuff I'm
really got to talk about and today is the
day to do it Sunday is the day where we just
shoot the shed and drink coffee or beer or
whatever and just talk about these things so
if you have a topic that you would just
really like to really flush out verbally
which we don't always have a chance to do
here please please stop by the Discord and
get on stage and raise your hand and any
topic goes really any topic goes so I
appreciate having a sit over here anyway to
shift gears right now and walk away for a
bit in the meantime and I'll put a little
bit of music back on. We'll talk to you B
bye-byealright so let's go back to
all right so I'm going to take a quick just
another 10 minutes or so I'll be right back
maybe DOTA tonight yeah
maybe it's it is Sunday after all
what you want to do a little bit more
on this demesne modeling stuff that's really
boring and if people don't like it but I
know I need to work on it and I got here
psoas stretch
like I can be drinking coffee all day and
still still be cold I turn the music back on
again thanks to all the people who
participated today in the conversations
I love conversations on Sunday I think it's
one of the best things that
that which offers us name some reduction
idea
I'm trying to run a local handshake doesn't
work I already have small guided how to use
handshake me a network that's super cool
Frank what's the traffic on Archer Private
Industry contracts yes
when the government is allows reggae for him
every communication has consequences yes oh
boy yes
oh boy yes
question is do I have enough I feel like I
got enough of these things the reason I'm
going through all this documentation is
I want to figure out where things go
CI I'm going to try samples Kilauea ml
so the eunuch is a boost
skills. Why haven't you come home
but you have a chief or title
set up an FS is a skill
how it was going to write it as if it would
be written in a job description
oh yeah, soon as I heard the sirens the
names fight
ax4n FS
directories next next
Maranatha storage on Linux oh God
that's fucking weird
terrifying yeah
XSport in FS storage
yeah I'm part about this is it's almost
impossible to distinguish between
ask Elena task because the parameters for
amateur ization if you just say set up in a
fast that's like really fucking broad right
so he says set up an FS and there's like X1
at the storage on Linux
that's the part I'm afraid of this is the
part that makes me just like you just want
to run screaming and go to if I do too
because this is too much stuff
a series practices internet more than one
egg
I'm trying to come up with I'm just using
the recent project as a as a an example but
I'm trying to come up with job descriptions
suitable titles for skills that would have
been covered by
by that you know
so
sorry honey I know I'm not talking about
titles and talking about it doesn't matter
so
the lab manifest fragrant lab right so
what's this song
What is one of the skills install and
configure vagrants
would be a skill
I already we do this do we say vagrant
install and configure vagrant create a
recipe vagrant create a thing you know what
I mean
and it's almost like there is some
categorization of skills Based On Tools
automatically but but those things are also
methods of implementation so setting up nfsu
know or practice and if a store
I'm just keep it to the topic at hand you
know I think you need to have vagrant
when you got different applications being
referred right so
vagrant install and configure right
they her install vagrant install and
configure right
I mean if we're going to keep these this
line items then we kind of have to include
the
you know
I give you something like creation and
management of benefits and limitations yeah
his vagrant is is one of the ways that we
did and if s implementation but it's not the
only way to test it out right so
create and manage in FS
direct and Storage
I mean it is a very broad skills right
yeah
mercy me a lot of skills are things like
networking visualization in a festive Sandra
yeah I know that's what I'm trying to say
this is this is this is the struggle when
dealing with skills
it's also the reason that nobody does this
because the amount of skills to do a thing
is implicitly so overwhelming when you start
to write it down it's very over it gets very
overwhelming it's overwhelming for the
people writing it down I just met before the
other people tracking it will probably start
with
yam a different way for you from people
that's for sure to you
yeah yeah
so
meet creating and managing if a story is
obviously a parent skill that has a lot of
things that go under it
the concepts before each step of the Boost
yeah I know that's that's actually what
boost is
braids said the Boost is meant to be that as
to give you a really like barebones overview
of the of the idea behind it and then just
give you a taste of it so you can go off and
do your own thing but there is some
hand-holding there I mean you know
we should start with with project run
absolutely
yeah there's one doing the NFL has recently
on my mind I'm just trying to figure out as
soon as I'm so this is the only way that I'm
ever going to document anything is if I when
I go to create a lot when I go to do some
exploration of my own if I build into the
process taking notes on it which is already
overhead which I'm okay with and writing
down the skills that I'm developing as I do
them in terms that are familiar to me and
then we can come back and we can we can say
okay this is you know this is what you're
doing here
and I if I can get that to become something
of a book of a common practice we can get
other people to do the same thing and
collaboratively we can end up documenting
the shit out of millions of skills Millions
literally there will be so many skills
listed individually that we can search for
them and then associate them that's the hard
part is going to be with this is it is to
get coming ality across the board for skills
to certain people skills are going to be are
going to match another there does need to be
your unique identifier for a skill at some
point and it can't be the title you know
and how would that's what I'm doing this for
a while cuz I'm trying to figure out how do
we write it down and I'm just doing it in
Seattle right now but they're there is the
notion of all the same challenges that we
had in the saddle cast didn't apply to
skills there just in a different way where I
can make a separate people for everyone
right
and yeah I know
I can this is really messy but I I can make
a set for each skill
Hulett tattoo I already I already have been
doing that
I already have been doing that at how's it
going just be so every time every time I
like make a little note about how to do
something I document that thing as a zet
this is a skill you sex wearing a festival
today in FSX sports that's a skill
use entity what I'm trying to say is I think
I might already have the structure for all
this
I just billed zet into Universal AFK tool
yeah I think I might need you to
I think I might need to resend What if I
if I say use in a fist to export value now I
have a unique identifier for the skill as
well because it's it's already uniquely
identified within the scope of all the
skills that I've listed and now I can go
find them and now the only thing we need to
do is is tagit
we see the tag shit I I know this is sloppy
but this does the job
tags skill
plant plan simple lot we agree
so yeah is exported validate in a physical
and this time I think I think I think we're
onto something here
because now we have a universal place to put
all the stuff and if we want to make another
thing then we just say hey this other skill
over here is related to it
how to teach things actions and not so much
of academic talk yeah programmatically you
know practically a practical application for
my official committee are you going to going
to be beautiful I don't know anything that's
going to take time
I'm not going to do cell
yeah I thought it making it a non-profit I
definitely want to do that at some point if
if we can get that organized that would be
fantastic
I'm right I'm trying to organize a
non-profit before it's a pain in the ass to
take straight crazy as a Time
where do you see if it'd be a skill and
attached though
that's kind of sad cookies that's that's
what I was touching on earlier that the
crossover between skills and task is really
annoying right because as soon as you put a
parameter on something like setting up NFS
right setting up NFS with XpertThief s is a
specific method implementation of how to set
up you know it's like a specific thing it
doesn't so you could argue that setting up
NFS and sewing configuring NFS is a specific
method of adding a storage class and see
what you get is to get this crossover
between tasks and skills where one
implementation with Brett and one for a
motorized thing which contain further
specificity is also a skill and attaching
same time and that gets fucking crazy
confusing really fast
this is hardly the community you should so
so so yeah
I I don't know I don't know the answers are
people
I honestly I don't know the answers I'm just
too busy buddy the one thing that I know
that has been working as down has been
working for a full year is dumping shit into
my zettelkasten that is help me to know and
you have no idea I've been able to go share
information with quickly and it will look it
up and able to have notes about how to do a
thing it's just a big notebook
circus are we going to face of creation
management of any pesto be a skill that the
actual commands or should you soak your
hands would be a task and less of the only
thing you can do you know what I mean so
this is it this is where is that cookies
this is where I get I start to throw my
hands in the air
yeah and and I feel like
I feel like that's the greatest frustration
I have with we doing this every time I get
into it this is why I always drop it always
drop it because it's too much complexity to
organize it all
yeah so trying to put this much structure
around something that's so fucking
monumentally Huges is really really hard
S&K Logistics capability not the actual
implementation they can you yeah absolutely
yeah this is definitely the can you and the
implementation is that is whatever the task
right yeah that's that's that's what I wrote
earlier
and yeah that the knowledge behind the
Tasker the ability you would ever capability
I like that word too
then one guiding principle when it comes to
skills is how would you see it on a job
description to me that helps break down the
scope and a net I mean Selena sister on the
job description unless they're going to get
really you know like install and use export
FS you know to fix nfss never going to show
up in a job description that is a detail
about
how to do the parents kill even though it is
also a skill knowing how to use export a
fast is is a skill right if you don't know
the arguments for it is a learning about
export fast and everything it does is a
skill you should read it you should read
them and Paige on it you should know all the
commands for it read all the arguments for
it so you can do it to do with particular
task using that specific tool and you know I
mean it gets it just gets crazy
believe in me believe in the me that
believes in you
I just goes my current job I always tell
them it still isn't just learning something
if you know a language backwards or forwards
is great but do you not know how to apply or
no just as hell yeah
yeah the skill to me this kill is
yeah I applied automatically applied
knowledge is just the theoretical
information and terms and definitions and
why the why and the skill is doing something
with the knowledge and it specifically the
task is doing something one time
specifically with a specifics a bit of skill
knowledge it's an execution of a skill
yeah so
but you can't fight yeah right yeah I can do
it and I can execute on that but what am I
doing it for right with these parameters of
I control the board yeah so so I remain
frustrated by this I I continue to be
frustrated but all I want to do is
know what to do when I do a lot when I
learned of that n f s
you know what am I what am I doing what is
the process right well I think the process
is I create a Lobby that's public or private
where I go about exploring a bunch of stuff
and then I said about making several several
entries that match what I see as a skill at
the scope that I feel needs a full settle
right and then I write as metal and in the
net that does that all describes how to do
the thing it contains it's my recipe
basically and that's my implementation of
that skill in the skills title is in the
name is the name of the metal and the unique
identifier for that skill is unique
identifier for that settle and then I can
tag it is a skill and I can pull all the
skills out of my total capstan by just
looking at them and if we stick with that
that remains very personal enemy if that's a
question we'll how do you bubble that up
into something else right and I feel like
we might be able to just use tagging and
zettelkasten in trees and say
we could create tools that created index is
already have to create tools for indexing
texting anyway unsettles based on tags so
that's already a part of that project that
project already has to has to do that right
there's already a project that has two index
module and divided as it does right but and
then what we can do but if you can say Okay
I want to create an index of all the skills
while then I just look for all the things
that are tagged with skill right and then I
can create a structured data file that
provides an index in to all of my skills and
I can make that itself is at all or an index
and index at or whatever you want to call it
and then I can go to that and see where all
my skills are and then ultimately we can
exchange those or my nose out or whatever
and and that becomes a part of the knowledge
exchange rate in the neck case and that case
Ace a skills list becomes another
knowledge no data type do you remember that
remember when we used to talk about
knowledge and nodes
so I know it you know data type one of the
knowledge nose type is a zettel
at but if we if we create another knowledge
no data time this little casting format is a
knowledge note format is the same thing
that's why it's designed that way if we
should be in no time I think they should
I think they should the problem is that all
the artifacts that would end up going in a
knowledge known
and we talked about that too right and I
believe that's the decision to be made by
the people maintaining I do think I do think
aloud should be in no time and I'll let you
know.
I think I think we need to revisit all I
think I think we need to revisit the whole
knowledge note ID again
so the knowledge nothing predates
zettelkasten related sections your efforts
artifexian right and we've already we've
already completely structured knowledge
notes. And is that a casting that I as I've
implemented it is an implementation of
a knowledge you know a parent no Department
knowledge note on the knowledge exchange
rate it's already that it's already attacked
and a zettel is just one type of knowledge
and now we can call it said oh I think it's
probably the best way to call it because
then that invoke see how everything that
goes with is that all she would be usually
no more than 25 lines and you know it has
some structural limitations but but then we
can start getting about the business of
establishing what did the knowledge and no
types are what are the types of knowledge
notes and we have Dynamic types which are
generated from other content and we you know
we have indexes and how lines or some like
that so I think we should come back to that
I think that does that does answer that work
yeah so so so that
that could be
that could be a part of that yeah it is just
so much stuff here and we still need to
write about
yeah I think I'm glad you dated at Yellow by
the way
I've been really really back and forth about
whether we should use Json or a mole
I am I am still on the fence on that
particular point
Yama was easier to maintain by hand hands
down but it's all so insecure and
Jason doesn't allow you to write very well
and then we can have the thing where you can
do any one of them right
everything is just an otologist source code
that can be managed to such knowledge bases
are just local root notes on keg
definition of Jason oh well
yeah we would shit I ain't even thought of
that
yeah you can't you just we have to use a
mole
and I think we should smell it why am I said
I want a mill I don't know why I did that
that's that's just it's more normal to do
then
Jama at not not when you're copying pasting
yeah, does it have as many issues when you
copy and paste with you Emily
in Pace with the mou can like push it over
and it just works Jason doesn't do that
Jason has to be
they are very interchangeable with a hundred
percent compatible and it is an outliner
compatible format yeah not sure about the
Reese's yes so
so yeah I think we're going to stick with it
in a camel and the industry's pretty much
decided on you I will. Even if we have to
make a simplified version hey Ben if we if
we have to make a simplified version of yeah
I'm also be we make our own yellow parlor
and we we we disable the ability to nest and
all that stuff and we have Megan we have
taken to do that I wrote Megan so that we
can Define our own llamo the format yeah so
we can use Megan and say okay this is how
you defined its and then we will use them
picking it from the station of it and say
this is the day to definition of of camel
python yeah little bit
yeah we did that we did it because you want
to do our own person anyways so so I feel
like yeah
I feel like that's the way to go
I think at that point is still here just be
a type of zettel
I don't know that we need to do data on
that. You know what I keep going back and
forth with is allowing certain things to be
documented in the markdown
you know what I mean is the most universal I
believe I agree completely
I did ask why I did Mark down for that kind
of thing a strong part of me that wants to
drop the the structure itself completely and
and stick with and stick with Mark down with
it has additional meeting
because markdown is so easy to write
so
hey Mark. It's much harder to parse for that
kind of thing I originally I did that
originally they Central web didn't have a
separate thing right it would have at the
bottom of it it would have like a key value
per section it was bulleted you know I'd
have liked Properties or something like that
and I already and I have a thing called Tags
and if I have tags and there's just there's
just a section so so you can basically use
you know you can use mark down and then have
all the stuff be in the markdown not there
are certain cases where that's very hard to
do
hey if we're going to be able to have like
we're going to be able to use knowledge
notes as data types like extensive data
types where they provide you know pseudo
tables are replacing tables then we need to
provide like they denied me llamo or
something to that effect one of the cool
things about this was at one point I was
able to do this I was able to keg my get and
I had like you know like I don't know some.
Thing you know and it would actually go into
the ammo and get the exact property for that
so I could use my little Caston as a
database and I still want to support that
ability
at some point but it did the problem with
that is that so let's say we're doing the
skill stuff right so is a skill and me take
one
so we have this Earth say this is a skill
right
all right so it's a skill I tagged it as a
skill it's a description of the skill how to
do it
and that makes this turns to settle into a
skilled at a time
and maybe still is a subset or a property of
his own right I think that's probably what
we should do there
they're trying to say is that this could be
another way to do that would have been
and you know we've been this
god dammit
edit path hope I didn't delete it
I think I just did and got it saved
I did he deleted it iPhone stupid
I don't even remember my stuff yeah
so I can't here's where it gets gets dicey
right
why did Kevin Durant choose the mo I still
think Amal is the easiest of the formats
yeah it is because of the nesting
did the ability to Nest other objects easily
is really easy to do in Yermo
and it because it's your editing and all the
time I can't imagine if they do see a sign
for that if they do something else it would
have been still as the best pic and there's
just there's just no there's there's nothing
better if there were any better I would love
to hear about him so
what is it I was refereeing and it's not in
its path
I don't to to do it there is derp
alright so
all right I didn't do it
is weird uh oh
I said turkey man has busted somehow
if I have a broken thing I got to fix real
quick
Eric electrical xeracalm config
it says she's really going to go there
there's an eagle scout side so dark out
front
set Nico's daughter 1
intertrigo
if a coaster
hi
I mean I guess we could do now sir
if
do to do to do I don't need to do this
I saw you say this you say
zettaset exist derrico's
slash is that
crazy sex position and Yamaha yes no
suggestion for the date for the the the
integration right
alright so here we have asked Elsa normally
if we were doing this
Jason of them are interchangeable right so
for the most part of the animal yellow
except Jason you can rent a hundred percent
Json Indiana will file and it's totally
acceptable so if you prefer to use get Json
as your llamo it is yellow
the reverse is not true which is why we have
not yet I'm old so if you're going to
support the animal and Jason name the file.
Yamel and you can write Json in there it is
perfectly acceptable because Jason is
accepted by the way. I am on there then that
means you're accepting the animal and a Json
not just Jason but the reverse is not true
so
so are you dating right now
any one of the things would be the date of
type right
it's so this thing about establishing with
Dave types are
and I don't even remember what the speck was
but we would put something in here to try to
find what type it is like at your at your
eye
I simplify Pennock markdown dragon cayenne
and can tap best beers out of a truck so
here we go this is a thing and it's like
looking up stuff
if you ask questions I mean I need to go
back and read all this again
I do want to keep the the structured data
ability as well do as well
so I don't know what it would be I think it
was like
was it was it like datatype we had some
reserved for some reserved ones then we
would have liked
actually I think it was this I think we had
type and then you know you have like a scale
right
are we doing that I feel like is is is where
I get think I'm getting at is we're
exploring the the exploring the option
thanks for the fine in the can type so I was
looking for that were exploring the option
of having types that are detected by the
markdown a loan that don't have to be
specified by a datafile but if you want to
extend that if you want to add a date at
yamel file you can get more you know a
specific about if you want to make a
structured data and stuff like that
interconvertible without a utility but Jason
is about nesting yet you can do it you just
have to have a tool in general named Jason
on his for a tool it's not it's not designed
for humans is designed for a tool of some
kind and that's fine so then if you want to
use a tool
yeah so
I mean another possibility is that we just
flattened everything to keep value Pairs and
then everything can you store in redis
I've seriously thought about doing that
there's there's not a single thing you know
what let's talk about that for a second
let's talk about that for a second let's
talk about non structured data
that is just keep a pair if we allow for
that
and we use that mean you guys and I'm
already doing this right so that's that's
the idea behind could figure that it is
there is obviously there's a lot of
redundancy in the keys the data the total
amount of data is increased because you have
the complexity of writing they could be full
key every time but the Simplicity of parsing
the data and storing the date is really
really overwhelmingly increased because all
it is is just keep a it's a Java properties
file
and it might look ugly is harder to read
it's not that much harder to edit it does
you know cute in the stuff where you want to
have I mean somebody might make the argument
why don't you just use Json then you know
and put everything is he why would he have
the quote situation going on but you
actually don't get everything just has to do
only the only requirement is that everything
to keep a store has to be 14 line poem from
the line and you would have to figure out
something this is our properties so we have
some pretty lengthy descriptions here
and again these descriptions are
manage through software tools and then the
questions why don't we just use Jason right
I mean it's just as easy to parse Json is it
is anything else but if he was Jason we're
forcing people use it to land a man that's a
question why are we marked on the first
place using markdown we can come over
because you want all of us to be edible by
somebody easily we want them to be able to
go in and do mark down and be done and and
yeah just just nothing tops you more for
that right if you want to go in there and
create a date of schema as fast as possible
you can dump that into into a yamel file and
just be done you just automatically having
it just works then there's that there is
something nice about some for data
structures
you know what do we do we want to allow a
more complex data structures of data. Yellow
files or do we want to just say look you
know every single knowledge node has to have
basic properties that's all you can do
basically labels and annotations labels
annotations and and I'm seriously
considering that I am after having spent a
year with a pro-con list yes we definitely
need one we need to go look anymore but
here's the thing we don't even have to get
into that issue if we allow Q value
properties
right not what's more we don't even have to
have an extra file we can just put it all in
a readme file
we could and the original essential oil was
that an original the criteria for the
essential it was that was that anybody could
do it anybody could do it with minimal
effort and there was not didn't have to
learn the animal didn't know where Jason
they could just do it right and I think I
think labels annotations and tags are things
that the general populace understands
outlining the structures of zooming in and
out most of being really good at NSO thing
to it it's absolutely right it is way easier
to do outline content in in this try to do
this in the yellow file
creating an outline in the yellow file is
fucking painful yeah and because it's so
what we could do is we could extend common
Mark we can extend common Mark with
semantics significance at certain areas so
the first paragraph is the summary a tag
section or something effect when I did the
First Essential if I didn't even use the
words tag I use an emoji because it's
Universal and I thought it was kind of
quirky and fun but I don't mention a banded
that because if you if you put an emoji as a
trigger for a particular somatic section in
your in your, mark
you can use that to use the the you know
that the document itself as its own metadata
the document is the metadata right you don't
need some other structured data if you do
need structured data well what kind of
structures do you really need right I would
I would suggest you know if you're going to
do it then another thing to about keeping
this like this if you want to store your
data given a section and then make a yamo
section and make a store that actually parts
of the animal out of there
so you know I'm saying it's kind of like
yeah you like the emoji with the tool tool
to convert mg DL
if we do this and we stick with, if we stick
with a very solid markdown specification and
we have taken for that's why I fucking did
it is if we have a very solid markdown
specification for the semantics meaning of
the different do we have we have a general
to work the first of all were compliant
hundred percent with common work okay we're
a hundred percent compliant with, Mark we do
not extend that we that's our primary goal
secondly we allow the extension of, Mark to
to include late at La Tech so we can have
math in there and how can mdtm will be
helpful I don't know so then we have another
stage and that stage is you know we allow a
math in there and if we don't have some way
to allow Matt and most pandoc and golden
goldmark support you no K tech and and and
La Tech we're going to call it math notation
we have to have math if you don't support
math and our documentation what's the point
and Anna
Universal standard format citation in
documents so we can put that there and then
if we have a rudimentary methods for tag in
which we already have
write 11 mg and then covered it all seems so
yeah
yeah it seems the thing with the awesomest
of I'm starting to think that we might
I don't know I mean I like you more and all
the structured data but it's also not
user-friendly and if we were fighting
between the mo I want to come back to the
outline thing for a bit okay so outlining
outlining is Pei Wei easier to do in
marketown so let's say let's say that you
want to ride you know I know CMS Prudential
anybody you want to put in an outline format
do these 10 things pick from the fire from
the following and everything and then the
end result is this very very well-documented
outline right and then we can just we can
just stick with Mark down for everything
but but we were the original that the reason
he mentioned Mark Kimberly for mark down to
ATL soon as the animal form at least we
originally envisioned the awesomest
credentials being a very very strict yellow
specification so that that that stuff could
be exchanged their do you know at least
enough reason to discuss it to move away
from you more and to just use markdown
semantic markdown that has meaning and you
know we're already buying into a language
here right I do feel like there are some
extensions that we can do so for example I
have already been following the related
section concept right and do something here
that kind of informs this conversation which
actually allows
tags to be using any number of a hundred
different languages it's like when you
download the tags database it has the the
the English for that tag in any number of
words is a try to get at is the
you know the the specificity here with the
word related could could be added to a group
of keywords that that are part of a semantic
specification and we can stick with common
work
and I I I am more than we get into this the
more I feel like that would be the most
sustainable option for the most people going
for a Big Lots going to stop them from
having to learn a.m.
nobody has to learn yellow
to participate in if you want to participate
and you want structured data okay what's the
extent of structured data on the knowledge
exchange. Tagging so tags is a given and you
know I deliberately indented two spaces so
that I can identify the tags do you know any
consistent way and I think that should be
the thing at one point I made it so that you
can remove tags completely and that would
just be the last thing on his feet on the
file and that could be it too we could say
you know that we could we could create
sections that are that are detected through
very specific semantic things like if the
section is the last section and it has a
hashtag in the beginning it will constitute
you know the tags property of metadata for
the thing and but we can continue this kind
of idea and we can have something like
properties right
at or labels I think labels is probably the
better one
but the problem with labels is they they get
company really fast so we can labels
annotations right so if we did labels
then then we have right so we have I think
I don't even know how I would write labels
say the truth and maybe we can make it
we can make labels into is this where bigger
install comes in yes
so we could have labels labels could be add
to taste hashtag means a tag
yeah
and labels or tags and labels I think you
can cover literally everything we would ever
want to do with tags and labels
my tags and labels right because then people
who create their own semantic things I think
it's all about headers right so let's say
you create a zealot you want to create your
own
genotype for a student you know what you can
do name you know or whatever right you can
make you can make a title you can basically
you can make your own data types based on
the organization the document you can you
can intimidate a tight space on the
organization of the document and then you
could dictate the the semantics of your
thing of labels labels are very specifically
keep a right so you know it would be ocms
icims version equals 2
you know that kind of thing that that's
that's a label
now most marked down for Matt's already
allow this as as was it called as
most markdown formats allow you to put front
matter but I don't want to do for a matter
we know why because front matters mixing
it's crossing the streams and won't be able
to get the first line and get the get the
title every time
it's to indicate level SMS virgin
No Labels are because it version ocms author
you know what I mean
yeah I could do whatever basically
Willie would say for labels as we'd say
labels a label section we don't even have to
have that what we can say is we can say if
you have if you have a code block called
labels
you see what I'm saying you can just call
and labels like that and be done with it and
then and then they would appear
so what am I getting at is we can we can we
can get everything that we were trying to
get out of the emmalyn Jason by putting it
in marketown the difference is is it we're
going to have to create methods for parsing
this out but this is already how are does
its thing so the r programming languages
used to pain. Marked down and you can write
against Kobe Bryant blocks that have it in
there and it just itches as a thing right
with hashtag different labels are keep a
with hashtag don't have a I don't have a
hashtag now
they could we could do that too
we could do that it would just be really
long I would prefer to have a label section
be kind of be kind of clean
you know because if people could potentially
have a lot of them
I mean we could we do you have to have it be
labels we could just have it be data but it
really is a label right and if you don't
know what I'm talking about so so can get
pods do we have it in me to keep up you cute
is vagrants to love
cigarettes so runny
I think it is I want to show you because
everybody's does this community's is all
about the labels it's like a real important
part of it and it has been a very good use
of of of metadata in order to create note
Affinity in in things that only run tainted
alterations and all that's all based on
labeling and labeling is not meditate
meditate labeling metadata but it's two
dimensional metadata and it can go into the
STD database really easily could go in a
register couch or whatever anything that has
Q value pair so if we don't overly
complicated labeling at the other thing
about labeling too is people do shit like
this so they like they'll be like ocms /
right now that you can that you can name
space or labels however you want
and we don't have to create a standard for
labels we can just say this is where you put
labels and then as people make their own
content data types of we can make the core
data types the Quarry in okay data types and
we can say these labels are a part of the
core data types if you want to play in that
in that game you got support here
automatically otherwise you need these
labels in this is another technique that's a
very prevalent throughout all of the
communities called native world is you know
creating certain labels are a part of the
specification for a custom resource
definition of some kind in communities so we
can steal
we can steal good ideas I'm kind of glad I
had a full year of kubernetes to steal some
of their better ideas and to learn some of
the down sides were exactly Emily and aoyama
was a pain in the ass it's the best we got
but I mean mom and papa are going to come
out this right there they're barely going to
be able to use common Mark and if they want
you can give me the label what's 11 what's
anything I had to keep a planter stand
driving criteria for this entire
specification for the knowledge exchange
grid is least common denominator least
amount of Technology Progressive design
because we are making something that we want
everyone to be able to participate in and
all they need all they need to be able to do
is be able to learn common Mark which
anybody can learn in 20 minutes and use a
texted her the end they shouldn't have to
know how to use this front page web
development to or this Jason query thing
that shouldn't even have to know ya Mo
honestly they should just have to know, Mark
and then they say well how do I want to make
it so that I have all my students in there
okay well there's this date of time but just
make sure one of your headers says name and
one of your headers says this and one of
your head or says it's all I can do that
anybody can use mark down in a in a
structured way that thing is really great
about that is that we get all the benefits
of we get all the benefits of the dumb as
well because all the stuff in marketown if
we rented this right we can actually tagged
it in HTML and now if it gets wetter to the
web with a very very easy to use from Play
No JavaScript if you want to do anything
fancy because now we can just park HTML
people this is sitting is so sad about HTML
at one time semantic HTML aloud and it was a
whole mess of effort for the semantic web
which failed miserably at one point HTML was
designed to do this this is what XML was all
about it was going to be able to provide
structure for data to the web and it
radically failed radically failed and now we
have all sorts of dip soup everywhere
there's no making any sense of any of the
date on the web and it's really too bad
because people even use a fucking paragraph
tag anymore you know they did you whatever
the fuck they want to visit the web has
failed as a semantic data exchange it is
totally failed on that front and we have an
opportunity to do that by simplifying write
the bass line so they come in my thing is
hey ya open graph tags they're getting there
but yeah but so we've got you have a header
right and you have a label section you have
a tag section you have your main title at
the top we should be under this amount for
if you wanted to show up in my search
engines and the thing that's great about
having a really simplistic document object
model is that we can allow people to set
their own search criteria based on it so we
can have people create their own SEO tools
very simply and say I want to search for
this key word combination are this rednecks
in the summary of every single page that I
follow
and they can search very easily in the first
paragraph and you can write that code in
fashion in like 10 minutes
so because of the Simplicity of this and the
structure of the specification with regard
to how the content is shared and stored and
we are not going to barge we're not going to
budge on that shit like the web is done
we're going to leave at lockdown you want to
participate in this with your file needs to
look like right we barely saying hey you can
put math in here right at one point I was
going to say if you want to put math in
there you had to put it in a block and I
think I'm starting to feel like we need to
allow we need to allow Kate text map Mark if
you if you choose to use that by the way
that will not work and get a butt butt or
get loud and rendering but it will and it's
not a part of, Mark. So everything that we
use is, Mark plus we're going to do, Mark
plus K-Tech that means if you choose to use
k-tec it will appear as plain text in in in
your
change but you can use in a mathematical
notation we cannot have a universal standard
for replacing all of exchange unless we
agree on a universal model for exchanging
math which is the primary language
primary language of science if we don't have
that it doesn't make any sense that precede
and this is why pandoc supports it out of
the boxes so I pretty much every markdown
variation has some form of support for for
for La Tech or or any of them applications
that it came from that you know the match
Jackson mathml which is a disaster oh my God
mathml is a fucking disaster it's so bad so
so we'll use the international standard but
that's that's an extension for the science
community and we don't tell people about
that unless it's a hey I want to do math
with a okay well you can do this amount of
math in here you know but the standard is
common work and that means Common Market
doesn't mean you know tables that are not
supported in, Mark, Mark doesn't have any
support for tables by the way so I don't
know about that one if you choose to use the
table
you might want to use your get up flavor
tables which are the only ones so what am I,
or there's a huge debate in Nevada mailing
list about tables because they were tables
or just horrible
what's that only of him when you got me any
of them thing I'm not in the oven fan but
yeah
take your scientific notes to any of them is
this logic
that's the first that's the first good use
of you and them I've ever seen
anything that isn't text could have a
hashtag yeah yeah
that critic the color scheme here is Tokyo
ask him a generator for latte is definitely
the standard that's that's pretty cool
that's if that's seriously that's the first
real awesome you so many of them have ever
seen
it's an honor, Mark Plus
I start using commands that people are and
then you send me is that link yeah
it might my biggest frustration with is that
stuff is the dependency on get and get them
that's kind of scaring me
but it definitely has work so far so
this is super cool and you have a lot that
is definitely the language of
of of Matt so so yeah I mean if you have an
enable I'd love to see it
so I I I feel like we have some conclusions
here that we can make it so I'm just going
to put it in myself because I can pull him
out of his head and put him some other place
later create a keg
keg specification
conclusions so a couple of things looks like
Isaiah just use common Mark plus math
math for everything I kind of want to say
Plus get up
yeah dynalist
cream best work nice
nice outlining
what's that
Glenn plug-in yeah I don't know it's about
me dr. But I'm free Anthony of in the way
that you guys are you people are using U of
M is completely supported though you're just
using it as an extension of like a Max and
people that are working on the same system
and doing stuff that makes total sense
unless you already know them it creates the
set that Roku and you know I've been are
seeing that it creates a dependencies that
they prevent you from being a structural
engineer because you can't be productive and
other machines besides your impression of
him
yeah yeah
this is cool this is really cool
that's pretty damn cool I won't lie
and you don't maybe I wanted to give them
one day as a replacement for them as long as
you learn how to use them right properly you
know
I would actually prefer to not do this in
him I would prefer to make a filter for this
that would do the conversion for me and then
just run it through the shell script I don't
think this cuz this is this is for forcing
you to use been thought you were Unity at
school but I probably wouldn't probably
wouldn't do it it's just not my style
yeah I would I would prefer to make some
sort of data tool that takes in their inputs
and then does the routing for you
yeah
that's the only problem I mean a lot of the
stuff doesn't have to be any of them any of
them taking over so much graph is one of
them yeah so
yeah yeah for sure what's this one
LOL that was apart of all things what is
this about
I said scammer tools I feel really good
about this this other thing so
comment mark excel's at outlining
Oriental
dropped Emma and Jason from knowledge
no spec
you and Jason can still be included can
just just not just not far this back right
centralized Etsy Focus
focus on readme.md as as as the
Kant main content
increase semantics meaning of read me.
Organization
Adam add
add a labels unblock
to the end of the file code offense
to the end of
for metadata continue to
view
hell oh my God
oh my God we don't even need this
we can just we can just add it
I can put all the metadata in here that's
perfect
all I got it's all we need
email list what you talking about Mozzy
Governor everything goes I'll leave me
wanting something better side of my hand
yeah you didn't text base diagrams by hand I
can see that there's other tools were doing
that though I wouldn't that's not something
I would never put in them I like the Unix
philosophy which I would use a separate tool
for doing that and then I would import that
into my them that's just my style I I don't
I don't like Violet in Unix philosophy
unnecessarily
personally this is my mythis is my my take
on it minor notes public so fantastic
did you get ready to take a look at this
short match tc2 made oh I'll get that
you know I like these to be Lisa's but they
don't you can't use them in some shells
you can't use them in some shows so and that
includes any sub commands so I don't use
them I use I made a whole thing on this is
why I don't like aliases
I always says I only did this I learned this
the hard way I went to go use aliases as
filter commands inside of myself can do it
I can do it so I only use and this is when I
know I'm not going to ever need you summon
subshell
a visual exam function I'm not a fan of the
function key word because you don't need it
so necessary
and you didn't put your oh yeah yeah I see
you supposed to keep it instead of the the
to do the brackets this metal thing I can
see why people like it they like to be able
to search for function yeah I can see why
you would want to do that if you wanted to
just you all your functions in your in your
code that might be a reason to consider redo
it to reconsider doing that myself
yep a look I know operator yay
that is cool
give me the physical trick that's a cool
trick I haven't seen a combined like that
that's a nice trick
so this is why I love you put documentation
in here that doesn't have hashtags in front
it's a cool trick yeah
I can see data using the function key word
you got me you got me thinking about that
now and if our security is fancy it's
there's there's one specific advantage of
doing that and that is being able to grip
out all your functions
are you can still rip out your functions
really easily not doing this by looking for
the parentheses after the first word right
it's totally doable
but
does it make it more readable you know
that's a good question to write
yeah, I don't play with that for a second
tenfu
so would you some
some Echo some
so this is how I do functions right now
and then I do so we could say
understand what that mine is yeah I guess
that's fair you guys are coming from another
language
yeah yeah you might have convinced me to
start using it
and he might have convinced me I would do
all right so we do
so same thing
if you wanted to you could do this the
danger with parentheses in both Bosch and
pearl is it you never ever put anything in
the parentheses so if you come from Python
and JavaScript
yeah
the reason the main reason I like this is is
this right here grab grab Funk from tenfu
that is hands-down the easiest way to do
that the alternative to doing that if you
didn't do that I think you just sold me
I think it sold me on it I fucking hate it
but I think it's sold me on it the alternate
okay so there's two reasons a beginner might
not want
mellow systems have Bash
yeah but I've already from portability out
the window because I use double brackets for
everything
so that's why I started doing it actually
for the reason tell me what sites but I can
see a million reasons not to do that now
that it's real bad out I may throw
everything else over mashup
to be fair most of the functions that I
write I can go back like this and put in a
safe there and it just works
website right
that way I can have stocks in your batch
name this traffic on my phone
yeah I violate all kinds of things
panel systems I don't I don't give a shit
about stuff besides bash these days that is
a very dramatic change in my my Approach so
and I'm already doing shit that's not
allowed in the Shell like dots in your names
which I fucking love I'm not changing that
for anything so I think I'm sold there's
there's two reasons that I like this
the first is it doesn't confuse cuz I think
bash is the first language do most people so
they say look in oh you want to put a few
commands in a thing
why is there. In the name for this because
cuz of completion
yeah Bosch
that's why so I have built-in tab completion
so anytime so for example have a life
command
my life had to have right it gives me all of
my completion and to add to add new
completion all I have to do is add a I'll
have to do is add a function that has an X
in front of it
it's good that I've written that I I like my
daddy blank
yeah. So you know it doesn't exist right
now it doesn't get this so X. Foo
Echo Foo and now I just do live. Tab and I
have food and fluids completable because it
uses Dash so you can PlayStation and then I
have to fuck around with anything else
so now I don't have it right much do limes
have done
no I don't have anymore so that code is at
the bottom here it's in my standard
this is my completion delegation of it
this is all it takes to do control the
secret going to come in like a lesion
delegation if you're just interested in that
stuff here's that eats for that
you just get that particular code if you
want
and yeah it goes through Alexa commands
as bad as somebody fall to an usher yeah and
thanks for being such a plan is easier if
you need it yeah
yeah I've moved to Bashas my standard
because it's safer primarily because it's
safer and more powerful like by far itself
up more battery life our hands down under
undeniably the most powerful shell on the
planet and it definitely is way more
powerful than Powershell
how is this helpful for first programming
students because let me give you a quick
lesson right so far going to teach you shell
scripting right this is how I teach the
reason I stick with Bosch by the way for
beginners is because you're already coding
from the first day of get on the command
line on the link system you are writing code
and I love to hit that point really hard
because people think I'm not coding now I
can't do the terminal thing know your coding
and your interactive command line is coding
so say like we're going to say prince Echo
you know hello I'm going to say f you know
hello you know dollar s right and I try to
show people you are programming
yeah
yeah it's like they think they think they
have the you know sit down and master the
sing the first time you execute a command
your writing code and I'll prove it to him
and the way you prove it to me to say okay
looking member that can you just wrote copy
that is your mouse whatever now we're going
to go open a file with nana leaves don't
know if I have not on here
he is not on here okay and then you paste it
and see paste it on hers this is an absolute
being a right and say okay look you just
wrote code let's save it I don't even know
how to save
I know I'm using that right say okay now
it's the script
I hate this show I hate it I don't
understand why people use it other than this
is our fault and they don't know better
it doesn't provide any additions and in fact
it creates a dangerous one I did a lot of
reviews the show and there's 13 Elite
dangerous thing that he shall does zycia a
few script in Z show right if using an
interactive your interactive show if you
want to use fischer-z show or something like
that fine I don't because I I want the
cognitive overhead to be zero between my
shell scripting and my shell interactive
line everything that I do and test on the
command line can go directly into a file as
a script yeah and so if you do this so we
can do here so I can say I like to do is I
can tell that smart
this is a lesson here it was Smart Plus X10
Foo
yeah if you want to do these shorts are on
the terminal that's why if you have some
fetish for making your your muscles and
fingers completely useless on another system
because you never leave your computer again
my entire universe is
is is all about being an effective
infrastructure engineer and container and
communities you know developer above
everything else I am not a systems engineer
I'm not I'm not a systems programmer item
systems programmer but I'm not like a a
software engineer I can do it I just that's
not my primary purpose my primary purpose is
being able to work on any system anywhere
and that is a much different set of
priorities than somebody who learned zMAX
and then codes canoe code for the rest of
their life which is like stallman did order
of All Star Vols use a zMAX because he's
dealing with big code based business like
that that's not my primary purpose so I have
a different set of Demands about what I want
to do so
it is go back to 2 or were they so if we go
back to this this Tempo thing right
yeah it's so and you just you temp / Foo and
now I can run it like what and I don't even
have to talk about the shipping line why why
don't have to talk about the shipping line
because the default for anything in his
script is the current running show another
reason not to Ramsey shows predicted for
beginners right because some of the stuff
that I'm going to do like about each other
then the next step the teaching development
and scripting is okay well let's let's
exchange is so sudden if condition if if if
the language equals
equals equals French
then Echo Lo-Fi an echo
Alice Echo hello Echo cellular
right so now we have a thing as like temp
Foo
and then you can say
so does it need to feed the case of dealing
with any system in a computer what they
absolutely don't they don't if you're going
to be a game developer and then we have
different priorities and go grab this code
or are you a visual studio you know I've
been part of this is picking the right tools
for the job and the jobs that I have
concluded to help people with above all are
primarily infrastructure in back-end
engineering jobs now the skills that you
were going to learn their will make you a
kickass web developer ridiculous you going
to call yourself a full-stack web developer
but they're not primarily made for web
development and there's plenty of other
people that will teach you that stuff and
I've decided to just not do it anymore I
thought one of them for years for twelve
fifteen years I was Nike's webmaster I get
it I can do it
can do it I just I feel like I want to focus
on the skills of infrastructure engineering
and call native you know Enterprise
Computing those are the the core skills that
I really want to promote that include
General skills that the universe is not just
for people that want to be hackers and
security people in back internal users is
its reverie one but some people who might
have professional disagreement about whether
that's needed and stuck me in an eye on who
I think is streaming right now me and I I
believe pretty significantly disagree on the
foundations that are required for you to get
a job in to go home and you don't need to
the world in any case I think it's pretty
safe to say he would say you don't need
terminal and I disagree very via million
strongly with that obviously the guy at all
I just I just strongly disagree that the
terminal skills are not required for web
development even scripting skills I think
knowing that it writes for thing you know
in other languages mashup sticker is going
to make you overall as the totally better
person as a developer. I don't know what
kind of technology so this is now he thinks
and I can go right now can you export
laying equals
equals French and I can run samfu and I fail
why did I feel
Eagles French oh, did
sittenfeld yeah so yeah and let's see if
that I see if I made any any horrible checks
security errors on that Chevy
oh
depends on the target show at Asha Bangla
what's a shipping line I don't know I'm
going to go read the wiki if you're not
using she'll check you need to start it is
so cool it's like it's like Interactive
Learning
Ben bash right I'm going to run that now and
we pass
she'll check really it's game-changing I
completely agree
yes I could tell you done that to yep that's
another way to do it yeah
many many ways unsettling
Thinknoodles French Tamiflu if I do that a
lot actually
$1,000 a string can I just come by
destroying an exit
I don't know if I did or not
so so what do you think of this all before
you go I think we can leave this one alone
now we can put all the tags here
another Alpha mini commands
bash commands I think that bash commands
and then we can have is the first line is
all the tags and then the other is just all
the labels
and we don't have to do anything else
against
yeah why not just use like help
or man tell me why I'm not using that in my
they get something wrong
help there
that's the section of the mash man page that
covers that case you didn't know about it
help is a God sent
as if you don't want to read the like 8,000
line met Batman page what is a plug-in
a readable cell the our package
I'm wondering why I would need to steal
something extra to replace something that
already exists
so it's more readable yeah that's that's not
going to be enough information for me I
appreciate the suggestion thank you for that
that's I don't give a shit
I'd rather use what's already there and get
used to doing that instead of forcing myself
to as soon as I install something that's not
on a container then I'm already got ready
and got Man pages on the container
so what's up cuz you are you oh God yes
seriously I said it says what is the same as
SMS is the is my thing
and I don't know if I agree with it anymore
I I want to do it but I don't want to keep
it as all comes as many things but primarily
it's a for a way of creating gamified badges
for learning
that capture a certain number of skills and
that can be earned and that have different
levels of Mastery that's what all comes
badges are that's what they are and I still
want to do it what we're debating about
right now is is is is is how to capture the
documentation that would go with such a
thing
did the person flying yet totally totally is
and anybody can Define their own right so
ocms so here's your SMS system in general
SMS yeah I'll come and razor for sure
if you cheat until they are sent to far off
I don't she and I used to make my own stuff
but yeah it looks pretty cool of a
credential manager system for learning is
learning to focus on cutting away and it's a
waste of broken priorities the teaching most
employable skills for pictures on tag I'm
going to need some recognition of teachers
offering places with teachers and mentors
organizing learning objects into a corner so
quickly called badges so badges it are or
what we get is based on The Scouting program
and you created badge and the badge covers a
bunch of stuff and if you want to know
exactly what the badge cover you can go read
the read the message out that I'm actually
kind of rethinking at this moment the llamo
specification for this which was always kind
of on the edge for me I'm not against it but
I am now starting to think that I could I
can possibly avoid
avoid and I'm wondering if we could create a
format and I'll give you a look at yours I'm
wondering if we could create a format that
basically creates this information by using
not yet Able by using data type
knowledgeable datatype and end the thing of
it is is that we could then all these
prerequisites in philosophy and shit right
this canal
I consider it a job interview the ideas is
it they would they would be self validating
in other words the number one challenge is
to learning and technology is knowing what
to learn that's the first thing that
addresses here's what at least I think or
you think or some group thinks you should
learn to earn the vagrant Badger the
kubernetes badge right, one badge here's
what I think you should learn and it starts
out by just just being a listing of the
things in the skills you should be able to
do and this specific at the time of the
writing of this it was a mixture of produce
this essay about this topic like you would
see in The Scouting program produce you know
create your own at home it would basically
have several built-in projects to it and and
then you would work with them into her
yourself to sign off on the badge and then
you take out the bed and then and you can
eventually list of ads but more importantly
you could you can list the stuff you
did while earning a badge in your resume and
we make sure that it didn't smell that's in
Leon's work like a tutorial right it has to
be stuff that you did uniquely so so each
badge could be could constitute you know a
segment of learning again it's almost
directly models after the Boy Scout program
the difference is that you have different
levels of mastering within a single guy to
be like level one of them right level to
volume level three of them and and at the
time I run into had five levels of Mastery
but I think we're probably going to have
three we're going to have you know Basic
Essentials you know and then we have the
fundamentals and then we have proficiency
and if your profession that means you don't
get a script for example and I kind of think
so
is that right yeah it's so and if it's if it
if it if you're if you're even if we get it
out there enough you get me can have a
credential
can have a credential that would say
this see this right here by the way. I got
distracted you see this this is me
struggling with being able to do a outlining
without having outlining I feel really good
that were throwing yellow out of this
I really do because this right here I was
like I cannot scripting posix variables
types numbers right so entry entry confident
and Mastery and kind of yeah it's a tough
word right eye that they words I was using
was Essentials fundamentals and proficiency
and if you if you add those words to the end
if you add those words to the end of the
title of the badge you should be able to get
it so and I had excellence and Mastery
Mastery for me was like much much higher
right that's like you can give a talk on it
and then I dropped Excellence of Mastery I'm
going to drop those because it's too much
so it's like then Basics right then you can
like them Basics you can have level one is
Basics been Basics Fitness scentuals level
two and then proficiency is level 3 we can
probably throw out proficiency put Master
either could change to change master to
proficiency make sense either one
and proficiency means I can I can do this on
a job Mastery means you know I kind of feel
like Master should be for an excellent
should be five that means that you've gone
above and beyond and you fucking written
books on it and shit right I just don't know
that we need a 4 and 5 level you know maybe
we do maybe we do maybe we need to have a
level four b b mastering when you say your
master then the first thing I'm going to ask
you is how is your interrupt you I didn't
learn bench with okay then you didn't Master
Vin
if you can't say you master kneel then
without mastering Lua if you haven't written
Lua plug-ins any of them you have not
mastered the Bap location
that's a master a master we're talkin right
if you can use them to edit files and get
work done every day and you have minimal
awareness of how to use the filter command
for Unix yeah you're proficient you can
you're proficient in vent but you're you
haven't mastered them
yeah I think Masters really she will sense
things change so much more than any other
reason I don't like the word Mastery because
Mastery usually means that you know I feel
like it could be low before though I think
it could be a level 40 level 4 base know I
have read the Batman page I know every
fucking thing there is to know about Bosch
I've written tons of code & Bash I could I
could give a dissertation on it you know I
don't but but if I haven't even Master bash
I mean I consider myself pretty pretty
proficient with bash and I still don't
consider myself having mastered Bash
I don't I think that there is just so much
faster and that's I think the point you're
making that start with three and then
consider 4 and 5 if you can. I think you're
right sad cookies I think that's the way to
go I think I think I think the first 3 or
the way to go but it's really hard to
distinguish when something goes in a
category ever had that problem
but I'm really glad I have a levels because
this is why when I was going to do the Boost
yeah this chicken in the egg situation right
so let me give you an example in order to
achieve then proficiency you have to be able
to edit your Venom RC script
but you can't edit your Venom RC script
until you have them basic knowledge you see
what I mean here so you can't you see it's
so if you list the requirements for the
badge to be everything on the proficiency
level you can't actually fulfill it because
you don't you're not proficient enough to do
it
didn't even do the basics it one of the
greatest breakthrough as was the leveling
thing and then their badges I have that so
so yeah you would go into it you start out
you start out with level 1 Basics like okay
I can edit files and survive Basics I used
to call it survival and actually most of my
stuff in order picture I was like the I
Survived it's like you know like markdown
survival right VI survival and actually how
to think you guys might like it actually
yeah I survived
the I Survived is is how you can replace
event Nana with Ben into it if it's actually
easier to use VI
how to use VI the Nano it's easier for
beginners to learn if they are in the Nano
if you allow them to use the arrow keys
which would be something we would do at a
basic level
and then that proves it you can go look
there's only like there's like three or four
things I've taught nine-year-old c i I had a
bounty out for anybody that could find me
any organization in the world that taught
the item 9 year olds and I didn't and that's
what we did that's exactly what it is to
change so quickly so I brought it be and is
anyone you can play Master Trinity's yeah
yeah it says it's like saying you master
Lenox you know I hate adventurous I've seen
I've tried them adventures in the classroom
environment and found out why I don't like
it the best way to learn a thing is to use
the thing as it was intended my opinion I
thought I was going to really like I didn't
I hated and the kids who came out of him
Avengers had no idea how to use been
the best thing so far as been tutoring even
answer a lot and I've been wanting to make
my husband to her since the beginning yeah I
wanted to make a replacement I have knows I
have extensive notes about how to improve in
tutor somewhere and I want to take all of
those notes were actually taken in the heat
of battle while I was teaching people then
and it was all the stuff that I wanted to
change over news
I can't make the info from Adventure sick
next I don't know since before I cussed him
two games with people liking games is is
games don't teach you the skills they teach
you how to play the game
I hate to put it that way but it's true
some games like you know I don't know like
nitro type or something they do teach you to
type and stuff but
yeah I would I would rather people learn to
learn to type in to do Vin while their
coding because you know that in my opinion
that's that's the faster way to to do it we
are done in FS
TGIF I think you're right I think you're
right I think suffering through the actual
thing doesn't to is it all new mnemonics you
know the all the active recall the pneumonic
held at all this science about you know
learning is it you're going to associate
your VI skills with the task at hand if you
if you if you build all these other
associations with with with this unit pretty
game then they don't trigger they don't
trigger weight of a sudden you were like on
a command line you're terrified you're like
oh my God I'm using VI you don't you don't
associate that it's that nice happy them
game you were playing before you think it is
a terrifying thing what but if you learned
to do it that way in the first place they're
not terrified because this thing you know
and so I'm I am a strong Advocate on
eliminating gamification when you could do
something real and that includes things like
replicant things like where you go out to a
coding you code.org whatever the fuck right
and yeah you make a web page on the website
now actually make a web page while I don't
know how
you don't know where to put the days to mail
you don't know where you would hosted you
don't know how to get to file their you
don't know how to edit the file on your
local system cuz use the fucking web browser
for your editing you don't have any of the
essential skills for doing the judge you're
completely useless but you got your
certificate saying that you're a bona fide
web developer
I'm picking up freecodecamp on that one
I can toddler curiosity test to the point
that I agree completely yes I do agree that
all right so I feel like we've got some
summations here
yeah I was just
dang some stuff I got to make some some some
recaer and then I'm going to make dinner is
coming pretty soon I'll be taking a break I
will be probably coming back tonight to do
some more relaxing things like games or
whatever but I'm really enjoying this so I
don't know what our next the next Lab is
probably going to be tomorrow and we'll
probably will be doing it if it's shit
Jurassic I'm so sorry for you to have to go
there
are you getting over you do need it you need
it for the older that's why we did it yeah
this is been a good session for a dog
anx are also Central Command Center is an
arrow and I don't get you the end of the
line for some reason
for some reason I agree band in 60 seconds
the purpose of that is like I wanted to use
the absolute minimum number of commands
directly related to what you would have to
know in Nano so I literally said what is the
absolute necessary keystrokes to be able to
edit a file and exit in VI
LA Zoo hours on Sunday if you want any
weekly sessions if he works I do want to do
that I don't know
and BMO my God different yeah
yes we did was I said I'm kind of people
through there
yeah I'm not I'm not proud and the proud
yeah that's why I got so mad is because
people paid me money to send him through
freecodecamp and help him out with that come
out of that had no fucking skill at all and
I had to reteach to a mall
and that's her real parents breathing down
your neck saying hey what a my kid learn and
I'm like nothing like why didn't either
anything well we tried to use this official
freecodecamp course I didn't wash it and
like that and I will why did you pay for
Coke at me because everyone says it's the
thing to do and I guess I'm like a
significant thing there wasn't one of the
teachers that parents would talk to me about
a mostly parents like oh my God
still sitting on their kids wall and
meanwhile they can't do shit
I think there was a couple of parents I will
confess that I was like you know
I'm just going to let him think that they
learn something here and let him take it
away God knows the rest of the fucking world
is doing that it's a hose but I feel dirty
doing it I was like no your kid doesn't know
shit they don't know shit and it was
I chatted. Manager
as soon as you receive a tax Annex isn't too
bad I mean there's some stuff the free that
Lennox the freeletics stuff is pretty
interesting how's it going command Commander
Charles Charizard
fishing reels goes down
biggie Ikes is so Google just like
University degrees in promoting surgical
products yeah there is a certified
certificates work
and universities are not working they're not
to universities are not working by every
objective measure they are not producing
employable people
they're not it was like crazy so
you know the first thing I would say is why
are you thinking so shallow lie about about
University education the value of their
value of a university education is
intangible
my hell yeah it's intangible I can't fucking
eat next week thanks to your intangible
degree I got from stand for the cost me
$20,000.
Is suggesting to a university Professor to
somebody over there that that what they're
doing that they are not teaching people that
have employable skills makes them cringe and
makes him cranky cuz I think how dare you
simplify College as the college experience
as being something to get a job it's so much
more than that were expanding their Horizons
letting them do beer bong parties and
everything else that a child needs at this
age
let me just just consider the amount of
money we spend on a football team alone can
you imagine robbing a child of their
experience to attend a college football game
just so they can get a job something as
shallow as getting a job after they leave
College
oh it's so pedestrian how dare you how dare
you
did you hear we're adding Esports
expensive full degree I know and that's what
that's what's happening like oh yeah there's
money in this we're going to make we can do
better
the problem is there's a complete disconnect
between theater, that this is what this is
what we were talking about this morning
this how I started the day I started writing
about that I wrote an article about that yep
I literally wrote about that just this
morningeducation practical or theoretical
this is that is a little little little
thoughts I had on that
Sew-Vac it gets worse even crazy old guy
yeah go look it's insane how much money
they're dumping into that you know why they
can't get kids to go to college anymore I
feel like if we don't have you or somebody
wants to come here I want to go to fucking
football game or lacrosse for god sakes
dispense a college how dare you question
college football oh my God if you question
the amount of money that's dumped into
college football in America even though
you're a particularly Germany separates all
of their extracurricular activities from
their academic instruction my wife loves
reminded me that every time he goes no
that's totally stupid chess club at school
what the fuck Sports in school no school was
for learning you go to school to learn and
then you come home at like 4 or 5 and you
join a club you join a club you don't have
soccer club you joined in this club that
stuff is tied to the education system it
separate because it makes fucking sense to
do that why the hell would you like putting
associated with the thing and then forced
people to pay it then pay the fucking
football coach / Health instructor who bucks
cheerleaders on this side 90 to 100 Grand
more than you know more than the principal
dude it's it's so messed up American
education is just so fucking messed up if
you if you question Saturday night Friday
Night Lights football or you question in
college football in America you will get
shot in the face
if you if you like give it if you give him a
bill you say look when you question out of
the military spending you question Sports
spending or military spending in the United
States and get ready for a fucking fight
because they just don't want to have it they
won't even talk about it they don't even
talk about it confuses they are you see a
big future Generations terms of learning
absolutely be in the next life will be home
schooling our kids there's a lot of people
doing that we did some of those two really
great thing about homeschooling is that both
the conservatives and liberals agree on that
so if you're an independent or in the middle
or something you can do that in school from
8 to 6 because of the activities that my
school offered in the afternoon really
that's that's that's unusual
because you wanted to interesting over the
activities were they were they
with a extracurricular with a learning
activities
and I can't I can give that back to my wife
hasn't been in Germany and God 20 years
Google require University reason their job
listings not all of them but saying they
didn't require Matt Damon IBM in a bunch of
others in 2013 they signed an affidavit
saying we do not require a college degree to
people have the skill
other but I searched the same University
yeah
there's no doubt then Amazon and and Google
and big companies like that are Facebook try
to do to actually interview with Facebook
for if an education job I did not last very
long
they're they're realizing that the
traditional schooling system is failing and
then I can do to make money
and so they're not trying to make money off
the education so much as they're trying to
get people to do the skills so they can
still sell their product
some further prison for having an affair
with subordinate is sorry I was like are you
fucking kidding me
for two years after being fired after being
fired you kidding me
welcome to America
welcome to America America yeah
oh my God
oh my God that's just terrifying
Ayano
I don't know man it's getting busy right
here's the conclusions again I'm going to
drop the stream for a while and then we can
raise some money from it if I come back and
probably just be game to gaming tonight I
feel like we did a lot of really good stuff
today
yeah if I guess I didn't read me as the main
content increase magic meeting I've even
had.
Add labels add
labels
after
in final code in Final it's called a
Verbatim section I think
I dropped the Emoji so from now on it's back
if people still want them they can still use
them you can watch it and everything, Marcus
isn't letting
so I think that's going to really simplify
things
noted the similarity between
ZK and keg stuff alright so
is there any template
how to invert a battery Tree in order to get
hired I don't think they have yet we still
have to do that with a memorize that
which I can't do still I can't do it nope if
I can make fun of me if I tried I should
probably
I mean I lost more productive things to do
right
but this is the book apparently and
money-grubbing Gail asshole on the back
she makes so much money off this shit
founder and CEO of career Cup and the author
of cracking the p.m. interview and cracking
the tech interview has a strong back on his
self development have working the sufferings
you're in a Google Microsoft and Apple and
Google She interviewed hundreds of software
Engineers evaluated thousands of hiring
packets
as a part of the hiring committee she holds
a BSC in an embassy and computer science
university of Pennsylvania an MBA from
Wharton she now consults with tech companies
to improve their hiring process make them
have the coding interviews and we started to
prepare for acquisition interviews
I am not a recruiter I am a software
engineer and as such I know what it's like
to be asked to whip up for Lee Niagara isn't
on the spot and right Flawless code on the
web for I've been through this as a
candidate and as an interviewer and why
don't you put an end to that shit
because you can make money at it if you help
others do it too that's why
that book is unavailable on Kindle and they
make a new edition every year
it says it called multiple streams of income
I'm sure that she's very aware cuz she went
to Wharton
he's running a business he knows what's up
reenact
I know he started cutting interviews I can't
talk about them rationally I'll get so
pissed off and it's not just because I can't
do them it's because they're wrong
I also can't do them
Brandon operations guy don't need to thank
God it's not the reason I like operations
better
it's more about the stuff that matters
this is what I got from that is that she's
our peace in the quarter get a reason
it wasn't one of the turnpike yeah they're
not they're not they're not they're not even
objectively scientifically a good measure of
your intelligence or ability do anything in
that such as they really aren't go look at
the science on this there's tons of people
that agree with me on this most of them are
well much smarter than me
I mean there's our kicks pacification of
luden's and I feel like we can put that to
bed now
which makes you very happy I
I don't think we need to like stressed out
and all the stuff anymore we just need to
just see if you choose still cast and
linking and
some kind of structure will come out of this
we don't need to overthink it Rob
the badge however I want to still do
I don't know how we're going to do that next
so next Sunday
next Sunday I'm going to be thinking about
how to develop the Boost contents we have we
have 100 days left of the booze people 100
days 16 hours and change
so next Sunday we are going to be figuring
out
how to write this right now I've been just
running the outline form for the Boost and
make sure to hit all the points that are
needed to cover an idea actually starting at
4 for next Saturday because ready boost for
Community stuff it is very organic right now
and it's probably going to stay that way
and the outline of just be a guideline but
it's very possible that while we're talking
about it we're going to realize something
that's needed during the process I'm going
to adapt the I'm going to adapter the
learning sessions as we go I have that's
been a standard thing I've done at
steelstacks since the very first day
sometimes I throw out an entire language and
doing another new language the next week I
think it's really really important that were
able to adapt and be content as we go and
that is the greatest advantage of Community
Learning is is the ability to do immediately
adapt and to chase that rabbit-hole to an
extent it's also the ability to keep
yourself from going too far down the rabbit
hole which I suck at thanks for the picture
that is very nice
as rain as my kind thank you and so that's
kind of a rat and a lot of this is going to
be these challenges and I don't know where
the challenges go you know what I mean
I don't know where the challenges go
I think the last time we talked about this
the badges and the challenges are so they're
not the same right the challenges are our
exercises week this is the thing that we
need to figure out where these artifacts go
right so we have the Boost outline this is
what we're going to cover today right and
I'm thinking that the Boost will be composed
of some sort of combination of exercises
that allows to solidify learning quickly
challenges which are exercises that are
times that kind of thing and projects many
projects and larger projects that it that it
that are some of which are canned at some of
which area of your own invention and with a
certain amount of discussion and her
programming as we go so I think that that's
going to be the magic sauce there
and that's that's nothing unique that's
that's pretty much whatever you
that's whatever you know continent content
is
I kind of want to come over and put that
into the Moose notes though I forget
combination of and then we'll do exposition
exercises
an exercise and a challenge is kind of the
same I think they're really the same thing
challenge is just a funner a word
and a projects so what's wrong with the
projects are
General me yes they are I need to start
doing more cardio
I'll be the first to admit Exposition
exercising challenges
what's a discussion about that discussion
slash stories
stories discussion
challenges I'm going to call a challenges
challenges is just another word for it's
aanother word for it's a cooler word for
exercise
right exercises guy to challenges not
this is good this is good
oh my God that's got is really good yam
yeah the exercise and exercise has got a
spotter a challenges in a spotter that's
exactly what it is
holy shit His Brilliant that is brilliant
where to put that God dammit
they put it in my cake stuff I was in Kik
stuff wasn't
Empire yagos like I think I don't know if
it's there yet
I got it I got to put that down I'm going to
actually I was going to make it out of my
like I'm losing
exercise as
curious elk I nailed the difference
between so are things
yes that that that has been no no okay so
we'll have exercises discussion story
exercises
and and in challenges which is like okay
you're going to do your thing and then went
project project project project project
generally implies that something bigger
right it's going to take more than a day or
more than 5 minutes and exercise is
something you should be able to finish
within you know 10 20 minutes if that the
Mary most an hour and exercise should never
go past an hour carrying routine
yes
Ellis Pottery risk asphyxiation death yes
but then if you want to have a challenge I
know I challenged you to spot her I know so
we'll just say like how about a guide you
don't have a guide in the morning guiding
you through
Richard Shelton
I'm out of culture I see
oh God
I just have no comment about that nobody
here gets that probably better they don't
asaba why you hanging closet breathless
grasshopper
I hear no breath grasshopper I am blind man
cannot see
why your skin called grasshopper
I mean there's there's there's a Kill Bill
joke in there somewhere I don't know how to
make it though get on it get on it
I'm sorry
yeah I don't know it's so sad to my fucking
grew up with that dude I did I was I was
like a faithful faithful faithful
grasshopper fan
cell a serious discussion exercise
challenges projects
combination if time
cyst of
activities include sorry it's
discussionsdiscussions exercises challenges
and projects
but that's why I'm very late for a little
bit I want
I must be I must be kind of punching right
now because that joke is crazy funny to me
right now
Ina Garten category joke I want
I'm making you a category instead of tagging
into making it a camera from
CHRISTUS Health
it's unless you slam your programming it's
profanity yes it is
I haven't bad jokes
we do need to do like like yeah I'm like
randomize on the screen or something like
when I'm away or whatever
yeah that be funny I would definitely be
funny
oh man that's really great Ellen thank you
for that
how Ellen got is sub from an anonymous gift
her I was very nice thank you for that
we we reach the end of our Insanity for this
evening I am going to spread the love by
rating somebody without requiring
reciprocity have come to learn is important
in the land of land of of of this later
tonight I don't know what I'm going to do so
I can't promise you anything. So go ahead
and see what we can find this is a really
great recession I really grateful for it I I
feel like a huge weight off my body and
shoulders I really do by based on its
implications of a just made I don't feel the
stress of not knowing where we were going
and I believe me I actually stress about
that shit and it makes me unhealthy so
I'm really really thankful
let's go see if we can go ride somebody that
like raiding the big streamers old Golden
Gardens on again
let's see who else is there
let's see
do do do do do do do do do do do to do to do
to do to
let's see what we can do here
just a Witcher I am probably with your I
can't promise anything
I can't promise anything
I can't I don't know
who should we do this is my thing with
rating when it comes to rating I like to
read people that are hard to find I know you
know
it's just more fun
I was or chews on Leslie's on we're going to
rain in Leslie
I'm going to write Leslie with all seven of
yours
oh shit she has no connection in Racine
right now I wonder if she knows
trouble doesn't know strange 3 minutes like
not broadcasting
maybe not one source you're playing games
try not to drown he's playing subnautica got
anybody random oh here's one
who do to do to do grocery Tom Papa
your keywords pooped
and come Road
I don't know these peoplewhere any of you
streaming
I mean come on why are you not streaming
how is this considered i r l by the way
how's it consider I was not a real are all
categories where's my science and technology
where are you it's orange isn't even doing i
r l right now
who is this oh he's repairing yeah, I got
this guy's awesome I wish I could learn this
shit
ice in German resume German
we got inside to take anybody got any
hackers get any hackers
oh my God I have that exact thing I have the
serenity
I haven't I haven't except for its a Santa
model drinks for acne
I'm afloat if you stream because I have to
hide my shoes
oh I got over that sweetheart though
oh Erica streaming he's nice what you doing
crazy stuff
let's learn what are they learning what are
they learning
mr. robot themed room what is this about
what is this about end game. There's a lot
of artists yes
I'm not against again I'm not against off I
was making jokes about the game suffering
game. Everybody hates me now but honestly I
got nothing against them they're fine I
stream to software Dallas time now because
game Daddy because it's suffering right just
I don't like tribal hey that there's
somebody who got the idea for me to do ask
you for him
I'm going to 4th and right now if I had a
nobody streaming tonight what the hell I'm
gonna have to come back soon
is it going to crash Richard maybe we should
read some of these play Weezer
yeah we're at the rate somebody's not doing
something technical
we might have to I don't like that's true is
is Leslie seeing working at other issues I'm
going to write Leslie cuz she's funny
organic gorillas Leslie's trying to become
like a programmer we've been comparing notes
on our rental stuff for a long time the dead
boards are the pics of Ghoulia gum
Kool-Aid gum
do is just say hi to you say hi to Leslie
for me she and I and and Tony will have a 25
done trying to figure out how to do IRL
streaming stuff and she's getting ready to
do the whole Ariel string thing
red
oh she's going to be she's going to freak
out watch she freaked out
alright see you later do you want to see
Texas this is Texas